Mm,
Tom,
Papa,
ladies and gentlemen,
we're live.
Hello.
It's good to be here.
So this is a statistic that I was going
to tell you.
If you divvied up all the money,
all the money in the entire country,
all the money that we have,
everyone would get $179,000
that's it.
That's a lot.
That's all the money.
The U s 300 million people,
according to the 2010 Federal Reserve
documents.
So it's a few years old.
Their total net,
net worth of all us households and
nonprofits is around 54 point $9
trillion.
All right,
so that's $179,000
per person based on 307 million people.
Is that include children?
Yeah,
three of them.
7 million people.
So your kids would get a hundred grand,
179 that's pretty sweet.
That's pretty sweet.
Your 11 year old fat with cash.
Finally,
imagine the 11 year old or the hundred
and $79,000
how much candy can you buy?
They go,
fucking crazy.
Pool is filled with inflatable
flamingos.
Yeah,
there's a reason why you shouldn't be
allowed to have that kind of money.
Like Matt,
when I was at Disneyland,
um,
I was,
talking to this guide and a real nice
guy.
He's super cool because he's got like so
much knowledge about Disneyland and
shortest.
No,
his name is philander.
That's his actual name,
which is not a philanderer.
Very nice gentleman.
But he was talking to me about,
um,
sometimes they have a,
like a prince from like,
uh,
one of these Middle Eastern countries.
And one time it was a little boy and he
was five years old.
Oh Man.
And he had all these grown men,
like,
you know,
40 year old men around him if that had
to listen to every fucking word he said.
He said it had to run over with candy.
Fun to see the mouse.
Yeah.
He does whatever he wants.
And he's five.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
They said he has like ungodly amounts of
money.
He could do whatever you want.
I mean,
literally probably worth $1 billion guys
five.
So he's probably just becoming aware of
his power.
I think he's always been aware.
I think or yeah,
I mean,
but I think his model of how people are
because they're servants all servants.
Yeah,
he's royalty.
My kids would be awful if they were in
charge.
You would be,
I would be the idea that you could take
a five year old kid and give him ungodly
amounts of money and power is kind of
insane.
Especially with their mood swings at
that age.
They're all like in the middle of his
knee and like I want to go to the
airplane now.
I want an airplane.
Now what's funny with kids is when they
get tired they just can't deal.
Oh
my God,
they just fall apart.
But my favorite is when my daughter goes
carry me.
Like she's like,
can you imagine you get to a point where
you just like,
you have to lift me around.
I know it's too much effort to try to
walk.
Carry me.
Still does that at 11 and it's just like
I can't,
I physically can't.
I can for two steps and then when
wouldn't you down what?
His 11 year old way.
11 or she told me the other day,
I think like 89.
It's too big and long.
It's long.
You're picking her up and her legs are
dragging on the ground.
He,
especially if they want you to carry him
like a baby,
you're carrying a log.
You know,
like you can like lumber.
I wouldn't want to walk.
It's like if I had to carry,
like I can carry my wife.
Like I could feel my shoulders like a
fireman's carry.
Right.
But that's not it.
But nobody wants to be carried like
that.
No.
Nobody wants to be on,
you know,
they want to be a little little cuddle.
They want him nuzzle in.
They don't want to make it easy on your
arms or your body.
They have no idea.
Nobody does squats with like in the curl
position.
You don't like do a curl and then do
squats.
One time we went to seaworld and uh,
my daughter wanted,
this was before we knew it was bad and
we just knew,
we just knew it was a lame place to go.
We didn't know it was evil.
And my daughter,
my oldest one was like a kid and like
four or something.
She's like,
Dad,
can you pick me up?
And I had like that macho squat moment
of yeah,
I'll put you up there and like hoisted
her up right into a tree branch.
Oh no impact.
Knock Dong.
Oh No.
And then you feel so bad.
Like you want to blame somebody other
than you and you're like,
well the,
the seaworld branch people assholes with
their tree placement.
Uh,
it was a rough one,
but no,
she always,
my daughter 11 still still has the 14
year old is not asking be carried.
But the 11 year olds still have moments
of Dan.
I don't think there's also this thing
going on with kids where they're
realizing like,
wow,
I'm going to be responsible for myself
eventually.
This is coming.
This day is coming.
Yeah.
My tongue avoidable,
my daughter,
you know,
it's like,
it's like puberty time,
you know?
And she is so aware of it and she
literally said out loud the other night,
I don't want to stop being a kid.
Whoa.
And I was like,
well look,
look at our friends,
cause we've all had a comedian friends.
I'm like,
look at Erin,
she's a grown up.
She's like,
yeah,
but she's different.
She's not.
I'm like,
yeah,
but she's hung on to being a nut and
having a good time.
And I then I got kind of bummed out as I
was saying it because I want to say to
her,
look,
I'm not that much of a grown up.
But to her it's like I'm a serious guy
that's walking around scowling
sometimes.
You know,
taking care of stuff that they wouldn't
relieve her.
You know,
she sees me as a guy,
he's not having that much fun
the time.
Well don't you look at people that have
incredible responsibilities like the
president and you go fuck that job.
Oh my God.
Right?
Yeah.
Or Ceos of giant corporations are
working 2030 hours a day or whatever the
fuck they're doing.
I think you just get in it and you can
work 30 hours a day.
You just get in it and you'd go,
I guess.
But I guess,
but you look at them from an outsider's
perspective and go,
that is just,
I don't want that.
I think a lot of times kids look at that
about adults like,
honey,
do you have your passport?
Where's your keys?
Where's it all right?
All right,
got my thing.
I got that.
They look at it like,
oh,
what's going on?
He's got so much to handle.
So much.
Did you lock the doors were going out.
Could you,
could you call the bill guy?
Did you make sure the payment and what
about the plumber is,
is that fixed or can we turn the water
on?
Is it the though
the thing that drives me crazy when I
look at those guys,
the business guys and the president,
it's not this president so much cause he
seems pretty funny,
but is the,
they're so serious.
Yeah.
That's the one thing like is I don't
take anything that serious around.
Even if people are screaming about
whatever,
you know,
anything.
I just will make a joke.
I keep it light.
You know,
I'm not like clowning,
but I will,
you know,
there was,
there was a dead lizard this morning in
the,
in the washing machine and my wife's
screaming this,
I'm like,
could we keep them just to let the kids
know?
And then they come back from these homes
when they have like play dates with,
with real grownup fathers and they're
like,
nobody laughs
are there?
Oh,
I was like,
it's like really serious.
Well,
a lot of people's lives are like a
sentence.
You have a daily eight hour sentence.
Your daily eight hours centers is to go
to an office and do something you hate.
Yeah.
And then come home tired.
There's a Ted podcast that I was
listening to me,
uh,
come up with the name right here.
Maslow's human needs.
And uh,
I was listening to it on the way over
here.
It's really fucking interesting.
Maslow,
the guy or is that a thing?
Um,
it's a good question.
I think it's the,
the guy who came up with these needs,
the hierarchy of needs.
Um,
yeah.
Human needs of food,
asleep,
safety,
love,
purpose.
A psychologist,
Abraham maslow.
And that's his,
um,
his hierarchy triangle,
like the food pyramid,
which by the way,
it's all fucked up.
The Food Pyramid.
Cause I was reading a story to my six
year old,
uh,
about uh,
it was one of those um,
cat in the hat.
Like a,
the things you could do that are good
for you.
All right.
And uh,
one of the things they show the feet
food pyramid at the bottom is all bread
bread's good.
What's not bread's good.
It's not good for you Tom.
Papa.
I know we started a
Oh you brought bread.
You son of a bitch.
It's,
oh it's wrapped in a cloth.
Ladies and gentlemen,
they're like,
like,
like he's some old timey baker character
through it feels like the only thing I'm
bummed out about us.
I didn't have a basket.
Did you make that I mainly made,
this is a sour dough.
This is a sourdough bread from Tom Papa
that made it into New York Times.
Yeah.
When I did your show and a cat smell,
it talks about it.
And this is a couple of days old cause I
thought it was coming a couple days ago.
Yeah.
Ooh.
Did you even make the top a little
flowery?
Like,
like a real bakery and misspelled?
Oh,
that's also good.
That's good.
God,
that smells good.
Yeah.
That's ancient sourdough.
Tom.
Papa,
you fucking Adam.
You brought a knife and everything.
I don't,
it looks like we're off the Diet today.
Today I was at the lowest weight.
I've been in like years one 90 this
morning.
I really,
yeah,
it's crazy.
How tall are you?
Five.
Eight.
Wow.
I really,
uh,
I,
I don't think that this bread,
this is sourdough bread.
You digest it as a lower glycaemic
supposedly.
Supposedly.
Allegedly.
I'm in though,
Dude.
Just slice it up.
Can I cut it on this?
This is a couple of days off.
So granted this table,
it actually be good.
Like it'll make it cooler.
So he just cut it like it's a cutting
board.
Don't be shy.
All right.
This is a,
I mean this is how bread was made
originally.
This is in ancient Egypt 6,000
years ago.
Ancient Egypt.
Do you know that in ancient Egypt when
they made bread,
they ground their flour on like mortar
and pestle.
But they were really shitty and so
they'd get a lot of sand in the flower.
So the people in ancient Egypt all had
fucked up teeth,
like worn down to the nerves cause they
were chewing sand all day.
So the inside of their body was like a
fucking,
what are those things called on birds?
What is that called?
Like a,
um,
like uh,
what is that thing?
That thing that they do?
The crop where you,
you have your,
your gizzard.
Yeah.
We both fucking rocks in there and you
chew up your Food God,
which is apparently,
um,
one of the reasons why they made,
led shot illegal in California.
Cause like if people do like shooting
clays or if they shoot things and those
little lead pellets from shotguns,
right.
Birds will actually eat those.
Oh.
And it goes in there.
They're gizzard and they use it to,
uh,
to grind things up,
but then they get lead poisoning.
That's the thing with the California
condor.
Oh really?
Yeah.
That's one of the reasons why California
condors,
um,
one of the reasons why they made led
illegal for a ammunition in California.
It was because of California condors
cause they wouldn't hear it dump fucks.
So,
um,
eating pellets,
this,
you know,
that's not a rock.
You stupid fuck condor.
They look dumb.
They have dominance fought.
They really do it.
But we need this should be toasted.
I mean toasted would really be the thing
that would get you to tie right now.
Folks.
Here we go.
Oh,
I'm so happy to see you eat bread.
Oh this has a good,
it's pretty good.
I was a nice and airy.
I make the,
I we haven't bought bread since I
started this.
How long ago was that?
December.
Wow.
We have not bought bread.
Do you know what like bread in,
uh,
in your supermarket,
this is made with three ingredients.
Flour,
water and salt.
That's it.
That's,
you know,
from your sourdough starter bread,
like the healthy,
like whole wheat bread,
you just get it.
Ralph's or whatever.
32 ingredients.
32.
This is pure.
And is that just because it's preserved
preservatives and flavors?
And young people could show mad when you
eat on a microphone.
I know,
but it's so good.
Normally folks,
I would never do this to you and I'm
only doing this to you because Tom Papa
brought some bread in and I'm gonna
break my diet for a few hours.
The sour dough flavor,
like that little after flavor in the top
of your mouth.
It's an that's a bacteria that's
lactobacillius or something like that.
Yeah.
Dude,
this is really good.
You're in a excellent bread guy.
It's pretty cool.
Standup comedy thing doesn't pan out.
Dude.
I'm going to just go into it after doing
your podcast and then talking about it
on my podcast,
it just kind of erupted.
People were just so interested in just
this pure earth,
making something small and simple.
And,
and uh,
I think I told you when I saw you at the
comedy store,
there's like,
you know,
you have some,
you have some real man listeners,
like dudes who look like they're going
to call you for like advice on a truck
and they're like,
I can't get my starter right.
It's like there's some like,
and people would start sending me
pictures of,
there's bread and pictures of their
sourdough and then this guy from the New
York Times,
Sam sift in the editor,
it was doing an article on it.
So he contacted me and I was part of
this sour dough.
This whole thing about people keep their
sourdough starter like a pet.
So it was kind of like this revival of
this little method.
So I ended up in this article in the New
York Times.
Yeah,
I read it.
I had a lot of people send me articles
about starters to yeah,
like people in England than have 150
year old starters and all this crazy
shit weird.
It's so good that I'd never even heard
about until you brought it up.
I have no idea.
I had no idea either until a month
before that I had the,
I was under the impression I,
it was with zero research,
just my head.
This is how you make bread.
I thought you'd take flour and water and
eggs and yeast.
Yeah.
You add used poor Euston and that's all
I thought.
I didn't,
I never knew that you had like did you
take flour and mix it with water and
then you get east out of the air?
Yeah.
When you told me that and I was like,
yeah,
get the fuck out here.
That's crazy.
Just floating around this all the time,
but did you know that that's what the
case with nitrogen?
Yeah,
like the reason why there's so many
people on this planet,
and this is from a radio lab podcast
that highlighted,
I think it was called the bad show,
but the,
the radiolab podcast was highlighting
how sometimes really bad people do
really good things or really good.
It's sometimes it's difficult to
differentiate between someone who's bad
or good because what they've done is so
amazing.
Right.
Well,
this is a guy named Fritz harbor and
Fritz Haber was a scientist in Germany
and what harbor did was he figured out a
way to extract nitrogen from the air
because apparently our air is mostly
nitrogen.
It's a massive part of what's in the air
is nitrogen.
Okay.
I don't know what percentage young
Jamie,
what percentage?
Jamie.
Jamie,
please put percentage of the oxygen.
You're like the five year old
surrounding the five year old.
No,
no.
Like I want to know how much nitrogen is
in the air.
Amy,
what does it say?
20% okay,
so okay,
by all by volume.
Dry Air contains 78% nitrogen,
20% oxygen.
Wow.
78% nitrogen.
So the air is mostly nitrogen and we
need nitrogen for fertilizer.
So Fritz harbor came up with this method
called the hopper method of extracting
nitrogen from air and that is what we
use primarily for fertilizer.
It's a big part of what we need to make
sure that the ground is viable for
growing food.
While the harbor method is responsible
for the nitrogen,
apparently that's in 50% of the people
on the planet extracted directly from
the harbor method.
What do you mean in the people?
The pee,
the nitrogen from from say if you grow
plants right and you eat those plants,
the nitrogen that gets in your body from
those plants,
50% of it is coming from this one guy's
method that he invented in world war one
crazy.
It is crazy.
Crazy.
So what was in us in the 18 hundreds
fertilizer from fish,
things like that,
like you,
you'd have to get mulch and compost.
And that's how a lot of people do it
today with organic farming they use,
right?
Like at my house,
we take our chicken eggs and,
and things that we don't eat and it goes
into this pile with leaves and Oh yeah,
yeah.
You have to compost is tricky.
Like,
yeah,
it's,
you have to kind of create an
environment for bacteria and stuff to
grow.
And when plants eat,
they don't just eat water.
Right.
It's not just photosynthesis,
but they also need nutrients from the
soil and they get their nutrients in the
soil from dead things from decaying
bodies for right.
You know,
from worms and bugs and all kinds of
shit.
Well this guy,
Fritz Haber,
figured out how to get the nitrogen in
order to fertilize the ground.
He just getting it out of the air.
But he also created Zyklon b client a,
and b,
the shit that they used to kill a Jews
in the concentration camps that kind of
created that.
But he actually did the eval name,
you know,
that's bad shit.
As soon as they say as I close icon,
that's why I say it right as I call him.
Um,
so he came up with Xy clon a in Zyklon a
was this gas,
but there was a scent attached to it so
that you could smell it right.
So that you could know it's dangerous.
Get the fuck deafness.
The Nazis switched it to Zyklon b.
They took out that smell and that's what
they used to gas people in the
concentration camps.
So Fritz Haber,
who by the way was a Jew,
his harbor method created this horrible
thing.
He also was one of the first people to
institute some form of chemical warfare
in world war one.
They would use the same method that he
used to extract nitrogen from the
oxygen.
Somehow or another,
he utilize that method to bomb allied
troops with poison gas.
Oh my God.
It was apparently he was a fucking
maniac.
Yeah.
And it was directly his idea.
Not only was it directly his idea to
bomb the allies,
but he was like super excited about it.
Like,
really?
Yeah,
it's,
he just,
yeah,
he just had this power knowledge and
went right to evil.
Well,
sort of because he thought he was doing
good because he was doing it for
Germany,
you know?
Right.
But then he was eventually,
when Hitler rose to power,
he was fucked because he was Jewish.
So because he was Jewish,
um,
you know,
he didn't,
he,
because he was so valuable as a
scientist,
they didn't immediately lock him up,
but he was in this weird position where
he had to take a stand and you know,
like what he was responsible for doing
ultimately went on to kill,
you know,
untold millions of people.
Did he survive?
Did they know I'm alive now?
He died.
He died,
uh,
seeking,
I think it was,
um,
some sort of health care in Switzerland
or something like that.
I think he had like a bad heart really
when he died,
trying to make it there because he was
sort of exiled by country and they
wouldn't take him in England because of
the,
his,
he was wanted at the same time,
he's received a Nobel prize for creating
the hopper method.
He was wanted for crimes against
humanity.
It was wanted as a war criminal for
using this gas on the allied troops.
She's so,
it's so complicated.
So in one on one hand he was responsible
for the death of all these people and
it's horrible,
horrible way.
But on the other hand,
the hopper method again is responsible
for like literally they believe that the
populates population boom is directly
attributable to his invention.
Amazing.
It's just a side thing.
What is the,
at what point did it become a war crime
to use gas if I think nobody had ever
done it before.
So they just saw how bad it wasn't
immediately it was like this is,
I guess this is a,
well the idea of a war crime is very
strange.
It's tricky because when
you said like,
well he thought he was doing a good
thing cause it's his country that he is
protecting and it hadn't been done
before that you people were using gas.
So it's like why would that be a crime
at that time?
Well what's a war crime and what isn't
right.
Like is dropping a bomb?
Is that a war cry was drop a bomb on a
city,
hydrogen,
nuclear,
whatever you want to do.
I mean,
isn't it a war crime?
If you indiscriminately kill people
happen to be in the area that you're
bombing,
what's the crime like?
Yeah,
you're supposed to killing.
That's Tom.
Papa is still,
this is the problem.
It's of you.
That's what the problem is,
right?
That the chip grabbed that bitch up.
So we don't keep doing this because
otherwise people will tolerate like a
session of a podcast and chewing.
You're chewing brown.
But if we keep going,
that'd be fucking pissed.
Adam Cro will get more viewers.
I'm glad that you,
uh,
that you ate it though.
I know.
I knew.
I knew it'd be concerned about the
bread.
Well,
I hit a milestone this morning.
One 90.
That's huge.
That's great.
I've lost more than 10 pounds in a since
when,
um,
how long has it been?
Like five or six months,
something like that.
Five months.
Just go real clean.
Well,
I cut all the bullshit out and I started
eating a high fat diet,
a high healthy fats like Avocados,
coconut oil,
right.
Things along those lines and um,
I just cut out bread,
sugar,
all that stuff.
No car.
Well,
very little.
I get most of my carbs from vegetables,
but man,
I tell you like as far as like
physically,
like my energy level,
it's amazing.
I feel so good.
Oh,
I've never felt better.
Really?
That's incredible.
I want to try this.
I think a,
we just get used to feeling like shit.
It's really true.
You know?
It's totally true.
You just get used to it.
You get used to like people were hung
over.
Yeah.
You just kind of like in this fog and
you just like,
that's just how I am.
Think it's bad diet or booze or
whatever.
What about the GCL Kimmel lust is,
wait,
how did he do it?
That fasting thing,
that five,
five,
two diet,
two diet.
It's five days.
He just eats whatever,
like a crazy person.
And then two days he eats under 500
calories and he tributes.
He says he's been doing it for years and
this is why he's slim.
You know,
he's a lot slimmer than you used to base
to be.
And uh,
yeah,
two days don't eat like 500 calories.
It's not,
you know,
it's like pickles and coffee and then,
uh,
and then the rest of the days he just
eats whatever he wants to eat.
I can't be good for your body.
Right.
I don't know.
I'm just too stupid for this.
I do the minimal amount of research on
almost everything.
You seem so knowledgeable about it
though when I seemed knowledgeable about
a few things.
It's true.
Whenever I have these kind of questions
like Gel,
now I know a few things,
but if you let go into depth with me
about them and you find out how shallow
my knowledge true.
You know,
I was watching uh,
uh,
this woman came to my show in San
Francisco this weekend.
A doctor Rhonda Patrick.
Yeah.
You met her.
She now,
she hit me on twitter after she had been
at the show and was thanking me for
being so hilarious and uh,
I saw she had a lot of twitter followers
so I just looked her up and uh,
saw her on your show and she was really
interesting and she's like,
uh,
you know,
super smart about all this stuff and
just goes the facts just pouring out of
her.
But uh,
whether you're acting or not,
it,
you,
you looked like you knew what you're
doing acting.
But it's a perfect example because in
comparison to her,
I'm an idiot.
Well,
yeah,
but she was off the charts,
but that's how I look at it.
Right.
Paired right person.
Yeah.
I can tell you what ketosis is and I can
tell you why.
It's better to have your body burn fat
allegedly.
Right.
Although people disagree with it.
This is stuff like,
right.
Bobby Lee doesn't know this stuff.
You Bobby Lane,
he has a beautiful body.
Do you think so?
Everybody's into different shit.
Like a scallop those old,
like a scallop.
It looks like a scout challenged with
legs.
I remember those old days.
That was like a hot look what being
levee.
Yeah,
those like Victorian days.
People would just lie around and just
look like a lard ass and everybody was
like,
aw,
it meant wealth.
I know that guy.
I can afford food and not amazing.
Yeah,
that was because back then it was
probably difficult to get that fat too
cause they weren't eating processed
foods like rice,
all this stuff that we today like candy
bars and shit like that.
Coca Cola,
it just right to fat.
Immediate.
So like back then if you were going to
get that fat,
like I always picture whenever I picture
Reuben NASC I picture somehow or another
a picture of them naked on a couch.
Right.
Do you like,
do you have like,
like when you think of like overweight
people from that part time I was
pictures,
I'm like lounging naked food around just
fat as fuck.
Yeah,
exactly.
You had to eat a lot of food back then.
A lot.
But you know,
isn't it probably until like the last 40
years.
Because like when you look at movies,
even like in the 60s,
everybody,
either the extras,
the stars beyond the stars,
just the people and they're all thin.
They're all thin.
They're just not the puffiness that we
all have now.
There's a puffiness that comes because
we're trying to eat this bread.
We think it's whole wheat bread from the
store and it's got sugar.
It's got fruit,
it's got stuff in it that's puffing us
up.
That didn't exist even in the sixties
and seventies a big part is corn syrup.
Did you ever see king corn?
Yeah,
no.
It's amazing.
It's a crazy documentary with these
guys.
They're students and they,
um,
they,
they go and they get their body examine
and they examine the doctor who does the
tests on them,
examines their carbon and their body and
finds out that most of it comes from
corn.
And they were
like,
what?
Like,
what in the fuck is that?
So it sends them on this journey where
they start examining the role that corn
plays in our diet and food.
And they ultimately went and,
um,
they got their own farmland and started
growing some corn,
but they go into the whole process of
corn,
how corn is subsidized by the u s
government and how much corn is in
different products that we eat.
So these guys go to the supermarket and
they walked down the aisle and just
randomly start grabbing stuff and find
out this says corn protein.
This has corn syrup that says this and
that and that and this.
And fucking,
they use corn for everything every then,
and even the,
even the meat is all corn fed animals.
Yes.
And that's why they're so fat and the,
and they shouldn't be eating corn.
Exactly.
Well then when you,
when you have steak and it's corn fed,
that big thick layer of fat and the
marbling,
which we call marbling.
Yeah.
That's like the cow dying.
I think that's a cow being a fat fuck.
And you're like,
yeah,
I know.
The tasty pie.
That's evil.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
but it's,
it's weird.
Yeah.
It's weird that we liked,
I mean,
tastes good though.
God Damn it.
But to think that you,
I know a fatty piece of meat,
I know a fat thick Ribeye,
it's well marbled,
uh,
go lord.
Why is it so good if it's bad for you?
So good.
Why the good things bad for you tom
pile?
I don't know.
It's because of the,
you God wants you to come see him and
heaven is that whole sweetie.
That's awesome.
My,
my new movement is to,
uh,
try and not eat factory farmed meat and
which basically means you're not eating
meat most of the time.
Like you can't eat it when you're out.
You can't eat Pepperoni Pizza,
candy.
You know what I mean?
Like if you really want to try and know
exactly where your meat is coming from,
you're basically cutting a ton of meat
out of your diet because you,
you can for home use,
go to a farmer's market,
pick up,
you know,
beef that is grown by,
raised it by this local cattle hand.
But,
uh,
just to go out in the world on the road
and just be like,
I'm only going to eat me where I know
where it's come from.
Look at a room service menu.
Yeah.
That's not going to happen.
You'd have to go to
a restaurant where you knew what the
farm was that they'd got it from,
which she,
there's a lot of those now.
Yeah.
I mean,
yeah.
I mean you,
you know,
you go to these places now and they say
farm raised and farm to table places.
Yeah.
There's a lot more.
And cities,
I'd never had it either.
Like you gotta like Cleveland,
which was the Tory is for like,
you know,
not giving a shit about their diet and
now is a lot of them.
This is like that.
Yeah.
Well I think the Internet has sort of
expanded people's idea of what food is.
And I think a lot of chefs who really
enjoy food but don't really enjoy this
whole idea of factory farming and
they're trying to figure out what,
what this gotta be on a more wholesome
approach to getting your food.
And so they make relationships with
these farmers and then they buy their
food directly from them.
There's this one place in Maine that was
on a Anthony Bourdain's show,
I think it was on his early show,
the no reservation show.
And these people in Maine,
they do everything and it's a short,
they don't,
they're not open in the winter cause you
know,
winters in Maine are just brutal.
Right.
So they're closed in the winter,
but during the summer,
Spring and fall,
they have everything on the menu is
vegetables a day grow.
Um,
and then they butchered their own
animals.
They raised their own animals.
Right.
That was really weird because like they
were petting this pig.
They had the pig and they were petting
him.
Yeah.
They were talking about how,
you know,
after you kill a couple of them,
you start looking at them like,
oh,
these are,
this is a nice ham hock here.
This is,
the Bacon's going to be good off of this
one.
That's a little,
yeah,
it's dark because you're,
it's your direct connect it to it.
You don't have that.
You don't have that like a middleman
that gives you a nice filter,
so you don't have to think about the
morality behind that little piggy.
I know,
but it seems like those people are able
to do it like it is kind of a natural
thing.
Well,
it's natural for farmers.
You know?
If you talked to farmers,
they get used to it.
Yeah.
You get used to this idea that you know,
you have these things,
you're raising me.
Love Him.
Then you shoot him in the head and eat
them.
Yeah,
exactly.
And look,
you're not going to get rid of factory
farming.
There's so many people that are eating.
It's,
it's going to exist,
but I just feel like maybe I don't have
to participate in it.
Is it always going to exist?
I think so.
Yeah.
Well,
it's reading and it's getting stronger.
I mean,
factory farming is now ending up in
places that never had a meat based diet
sending up all throughout Asia.
Yeah.
It's spreading.
It's not getting smaller,
but that's just because it's profitable.
Right.
If people just out
people jump in and say,
enough of that,
I can't do this anymore.
Right.
And the demand drops,
right.
We got to do is I've got to give
everyone in America all that money.
So they get that $179,000.
Right?
Yeah.
They could afford that sweet,
sweet farm raised protein hay back to,
uh,
back to the,
um,
the science guy that,
uh,
made the Xy clon yeah.
Be Spring Harbor.
Harbor Harbor.
So that's like an evil,
like that's a guy that has like a lot
of,
a lot of good in his mind,
but then it becomes like this evil kind
of a thing.
But you know,
there's,
you were asking what like,
what's a,
what's a war crime?
You know,
it's kind of fuzzy.
It depends on what side you're on and
how you're living,
you know?
And you could say the same thing about
being a terrorist.
I mean we see someone as being a
terrorist as being something evil and
awful,
but I'm sure like if you talk to a
family,
18 year old kid is like,
you don't understand how my family is
suffering in the middle of this desert
and we're being tortured by these
governments that came in and raped our
land.
He could make a case that would make you
think,
well you blowing up something is not
really a war crime.
It's you fighting for your survival.
Sounds like Tom pops a terrorist
sympathizer.
No.
Two things about Tom.
Bobby likes bread and terror and I love
terrorism.
Yeah,
I know what you're saying is that fuzzy
thing.
Someone had asked me that question in
regards to like the uh,
our own revolution.
Like when we started fighting outside of
the lines and hiding in trees and doing
some crazy kind of fighting and we
weren't in those lines anymore.
I was like,
these guys are rebels.
These guys are,
we're chairs.
Yeah,
you're cheating.
But I think it,
you could probably dig back to the root
of it and be like,
well you're hurting innocent people or
whatever it is.
There probably is a line we can say this
is a war crime.
Well what's interesting is at one point
in time war was handled in a gentlemanly
way,
right?
Like the leaders of one army would meet
with the leaders of the other and the
general would actually hand his sword
over to the other general and they
either take it or occasionally in a
gesture of good faith it would give the
sword back to him except except defeat
or except victory.
And um,
they handled war by these like very
strict codes at that,
at least at the highest levels.
And then somewhere along the line we
figured that we don't,
I think that was because it was like
super intimate,
like for war back then you had to kind
of be on top of each other.
You know,
you had to be like stabbing each other,
right.
Are shooting each other with arrows at
the very low and it's not that far away.
25 yards,
you're dealing with like much shorter
distances and then once they figured out
bombs,
like I don't even know where this bomb's
going,
but fuck those people.
Right,
exactly.
Where's the general?
I'm dropping this on to him.
I mean his sword isn't World War II.
The ultimate example of that,
I mean World War II,
when they drop those bombs and Nagasaki
and Hiroshima bombs are,
that's the ultimate,
I don't even know what's going to happen
down there.
I'm just going to let this motherfucker
drop this.
Right.
They never dropped a bomb in a city
before.
Right.
And this is the first time they dropped
me.
It only happened twice ever.
But those two nuclear bombs,
it dropped in those cities.
They literally were like,
whoever the fuck's down there.
Yup.
Tough Shit.
So long babies.
Yeah,
we're going to end this.
Yeah.
You drop a bomb on a city for sure.
You're killing babies.
Oh yeah,
a hundred percent babies.
Puppies.
Oh ladies.
Coleslaw.
Yeah.
GRANDPA and grandma might be kissing
right in the,
in the kitchen.
What a wonderful life we've had.
What the yeah.
Oh,
where's as being like the guy who's just
outside of the area that gets affected.
You know,
the guy who's has doesn't get touched
the just a mile outside of it,
who's just like,
oh my God.
Well there was one guy who escaped
Hiroshima and went to Nagasaki and then,
and he got blown up and Nagasaki to that
motherfucker must have thought the world
was ending old bad luck Jones,
this bullshit
ass war.
I don't even know nothing to do.
I'm out here making Sushi surrender
already.
I'm trying to read Samurai books.
Fucking dude's to drop a nuclear bomb.
There was,
there was a,
I saw Adrian Brody had a cool,
I thought it was a cool quote on a woody
Allen yesterday,
just back to the thing and be like good
and evil.
Whether this guy was,
was a good person or a bad person and we
were asking him about Woody Allen.
He's like,
you know,
it's just,
it's a complicated thing being a,
being a person.
It's a complicated,
messy affair and he's an artist and I
like his films and he's,
you know,
it would be irresponsible of me to
assume I know something of which I know
very little.
I don't know what's going on in a man's
life,
let alone his sexual life,
let alone you know,
to assume that you know these things as
and treat them as truth when they
haven't even been proven true.
It's just a difficult thing.
The thing I latched on to is it's just
such a mess.
Being a person.
It is a mess.
So complicated and especially a person
that's been around for years,
like if you're,
you know,
you're seven years old,
you've been around trying to be a person
for a long,
long,
long time,
you are going to make mistakes.
You are going to be at the very least a
mess.
You know what I mean?
Woody Allen though,
where you're standing,
like when you stand against him.
Yeah.
You're not just standing against a human
being who may or may not have done some
fucked up things,
but you're also standing against the
idea of people doing the things that he
is alleged to have done.
Like sexual abuse of minors.
Right.
Well you know,
because that's one of the things that
his daughter and her brother are
alleging that he did like his,
his son wrote an article about him.
You know that right?
Ronan Farrow who's really Sinatra's son.
Yes.
He's obviously Sinatra's man.
He looks just like,
oh sorry.
I said no,
it's really smart guy.
So first of all,
Mia Farrow was a whore.
Right.
Cause you say that.
Fair to say that.
Very promiscuous.
Well she just liked the dick and Sinatra
probably slang,
some good dick.
It's must be weird for woody,
like growing up,
he must've been like,
that is not my fucking kid.
Yeah.
Do you think he ever got a DNA test?
I mean,
Jeez,
now a lot back.
Then look at that.
That's me a foul and Sinatra's baby.
100% yeah.
There's no woody and Ronan at all.
Did Woody Allen say that?
He looks a lot like Sinatra?
I've never heard them comment on it.
Well,
it says it right there.
What's it say right there?
Woody Allen says Ronan Farrow looks a
lot like Frank Sinatra.
Chia thing,
I mean has been a clear example.
Those eyes,
the Blue Eyes.
Oh my God.
Look at this blue eyes,
but his face,
everything about him.
[inaudible]
Lips.
Even the crease look a on the left hand
side.
Our left.
Why the fuck hasn't he gotten a bug?
A DNA test?
I don't know.
I'd be like,
that kid needs to shut the fuck up and
get rid of my name.
Yeah,
well it's actually farrow.
Ronan.
Ronan Farrow.
Yeah,
so it's not really a son,
but I guess he probably raised him as
his son.
Is that the deal?
I guess he was around cheese.
He's 78 wow.
Addressed ex girlfriend mia farrow's
claimed their son Rowan and may actually
be her ex husband.
Frank Sinatra's child may be.
I pause for a quick word on the Rowan
situation.
Alan wrote in the middle of his response
to Dylan Pharaohs detailed New York
Times open letter accusing him of
sexually abusing her.
Um,
is he my son or as Mya suggest,
Frank Sinatra's,
granted he looks a lot like frank with
the blue eyes and the facial features.
But if so,
what does that say?
That all during the custody hearing me
lied under oath and bulking is just
fucking so that means while she was with
woody,
she,
after being with friends,
going with woody,
who she drifted back to Frank
[inaudible],
she got some Dick.
I'm a slut though.
World on a string.
Yeah,
for sure.
For sure.
By the way.
Me and Pharaoh actress.
Okay.
Most likely crazy.
Like good luck finding an,
it's not crazy or actor.
That's not crazy.
There's probably,
I mean they all,
two out of 10,
two out of 10 aren't crazy.
I've met a lot of them.
The real nice.
A lot of a lot of actors that are real
nice,
but two out of 10 probably crazy.
I'm not crazy.
Two out of 10.
Not Crazy,
right?
That yes,
I'm maybe even one out of 10.
I'm nice.
I try to,
I tried to be nice.
They go crazy.
And the more,
the more uh,
ah,
I was going to say,
the more popular they are,
the more successful they are,
the crazier they are.
But those are not as crazy too.
You have another just crazy,
you know who's not crazy at all?
Rosario Dawson.
She's great.
Super Hot.
Super cold.
Super normal around or be still with
her.
What does that,
it's the,
that animated film I made with Rob
Zombie.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
She's like one of the weirder ones I've
ever met.
You're like,
Huh.
You're not even like an actress.
You're like a normal,
like a normal person.
Yeah.
What happened?
Do you,
are you a moon?
Dangerous didn't get the sickness.
I want awards given Sinatra give uh,
his divorce papers to me a while she was
doing a rosemary's baby,
I believe.
Something along those lines.
She was like on the set with Polanski
and he delivered,
had delivered the uh,
you're hitting the skids baby right in
the middle of her acting well back in
those days to people just,
you know,
like a guy like Sinatra
keys put there had been like,
had there ever think of this when
Sinatra was a celebrity was like when he
became famous was like,
cause the 30s right,
right.
Okay.
So the 30s and the forties how long had
celebrity even been around brand new for
movies and film?
Singing like opera stars,
but yeah.
Yeah,
not like that.
What's my,
she was 21 and he was 50 when they were
married and she lost her virginity to
him.
That's right.
She did.
Whoa.
So he made that baby when he was in his
fifties yes.
What an animal that's older than us.
Dude.
We still got hope now.
Still got hope.
The kids doesn't even see my testic.
Does he know why?
Back then they didn't have the fucking
vaccines,
man,
you're the died or you live,
but you didn't get artistic.
I'm joking folks,
don't get mad at me.
Joe.
Redington anti-vaxxer why don't you go
hang out with Jenny Mccarthy?
They would just wait.
They just wait for anything that can,
like someone was fucking saying,
he's a trump supporter.
He's a trump supporter.
Someone saying I'm a trump supporter the
other day.
Oh really?
Yeah.
And then some,
some uh,
Internet thing.
There was like a little twitter argument
eating back forth between two people.
Mike,
I'm not a fucking trunk.
You can't just say I'm a trump
supporter.
I'm mocked the guy all the time.
Why are you saying I'm a trump
supporter?
Yeah,
it's up there.
They're just waiting.
They can define you.
Yeah.
They want to like,
you're a truther,
right?
You're a va,
an anti-vaxxer.
Oh,
great.
I was on,
did I tell you this?
I was on a,
I feel like I might've told you,
but I'll tell you again because we can't
remember anything.
Anyway,
I was on a,
I was back in New York and I went on a
open gym and in the morning,
and I was talking about,
uh,
Jim was talking about trump and that was
the beginning of trump.
And I was saying I,
I've met,
met the guy,
I don't feel like there's a little
something sleazy about the guy.
There's something there that's,
you know,
you should hold different standards for
this office.
I don't say where,
I'm not saying I'm on Hillary's side or
anything,
I'm independent,
but I'm talking about the trump thing.
The twitter feed goes crazy.
Uh,
hilary lover,
you know,
they just come back,
liberal,
blah blah blah.
I go,
I go on Larry Wilmore that night and uh,
on the uh,
on his show,
the nightly show and there's a story
about some girl who's yells at her boss
on,
on twitter that,
cause she worked for Yelp I think.
And he wasn't paying her enough.
She was complaining about being poor in
her twenties and screw the man and he
should pay me more and all this kind of
stuff.
And it was more to it.
But I came down on the side of,
we're all poor in our twenties so you
just got to suck it up.
You know,
I was making $5 a night doing stand up,
just eat your noodles and kept working
and puck up the twitter feed after that
trump supporter lover,
right wing white and titled Ass Holla.
White asshole is
if the Melanin in your skin has anything
to do with your ideas about how the
world works.
But you're free to say it now.
Yeah,
white privilege white.
But it just that in one day people were
coming on both sides trying to
categorize me on both sides of it.
Did you feel like you were in the
middle?
Like officially?
I felt pretty great.
I felt pretty good.
When you get back to that woody allen
thing for a second,
there's,
there's a big fuss about him now because
people were sort of like defending him
because he does these movies and the
movies are critically acclaimed and
people look at them as like vehicles for
awards and radicals for a career jump.
And so people work with them.
Yeah.
And at the very least,
the very least he married his daughter.
Yes.
See there's a picture the me that
defines him and this is why we can't be
friends.
You and Winnie and I,
you and I are friends when you feel bad.
Well,
I'm fucked dude.
Let me be the judge of that.
Let me see what you say about what it,
there's a picture of him with,
um,
Sunni's at her name on his lap at a
base,
a basketball game.
There it is right there when she was a
little girl.
And then there's another picture of the
two of them together when she's grown up
in there holding hands and they're at a
basketball game as well.
Wow.
And that's C as a guy who,
well,
as a guy who grew up with a
stepdaughter.
Yeah.
That's fuck beyond belief because my
stepdaughter,
my daughter,
she,
I don't call my stepdaughter.
She's my daughter.
She calls me Daddy.
Yeah,
she's my daughter.
How old was she when you were on the
scene?
Well,
just like she was little,
right?
So specifically like she's a woman now
and specifically she was tiny then.
So like this is the same thing.
I'm looking at this,
so I'm looking at woody would that
little girl on his lap and then I'm
gonna looking at woody holding hands
with her.
Like there's a weirdness to that kind of
relationship.
Yeah.
Like that's undeniable.
How old is she in that picture?
She's like fucking six man.
That's a tiny little girl sitting on his
lap.
Oh my God.
That's weird to see.
That is,
I've never seen that dad is where and
there's something also that's creepy
about his face in that picture and maybe
it's because we know that he eventually
wound up fucking her.
It's also weird that you don't see his
hands deep,
deep in her ass.
I heard sort of hurt.
No.
That picture though,
that face is like he's getting Daddy's
get candy for you.
You know there's like this some
creepiness to his face.
Obviously it's a still picture.
He might've been about to sneeze.
You know you've been creepy,
creepy face.
Fuck.
You know,
like you ever hear photos of someone
like that is also very rude.
Did you ever hear emos joke,
Emo Phillips joke about that?
No.
One of the best jokes I've heard by emo
Phillips and he's like,
Hey,
just qualified that by hemophilus.
Well,
it's a lot of jokes up there.
He's so funny.
But uh,
he's choke is uh,
uh,
woody Allen adopted soon when she was
four years old,
married her when she was 16 patience of
a saint and he married when she was 16.
So that can't be right.
I don't think legally you can,
oh boy.
Maybe 18.
Maybe they started dating when she was
16.
It's illegal.
It's not legal until that picture is,
that does kind of,
I've never seen that picture before on a
kinder and my,
in my,
uh,
obviously my,
my life,
um,
you know,
the way I look at it,
it's like I'm not looking at someone who
doesn't have children,
nor are you when you have children,
you know what it's like to raise a
little tiny people and then have them be
grown up.
And then the idea of like,
say if you and your wife got divorced
when you were younger and your four year
old went to live with another guy and he
lived with her until she was 18,
then he wound up marrying her and
fucking write and having kids with her.
See what I'm saying?
Yeah.
But you see what I'm saying?
But that is exactly what we're talking
about.
Okay.
So that's an intense flaw.
Huge.
But that being said,
two questions.
Will you watch his movies?
I've watched these movies.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's a stink in the air though.
If he calls you and wants you to be in
his next film,
you don't work with them.
You do not go no fucking way.
No fucking way.
Not like he's calling me or anything.
Did you grow up thinking woody Allen was
like a comedy?
God,
no.
Um,
I grew up thinking it was very funny.
Like his movies were really funny.
I enjoy it.
A lot of his movies,
you know,
he wasn't like one of your guys deeper
Annie Hall and know he had a lot of
great films.
I mean,
he's amazing films.
He uses the misdemeanors,
Hannah and her sisters and,
and even the most recent stuff,
the dice clay movie.
What was that?
Jasmine blue.
Yeah,
that was great.
Uh,
Barcelona.
Yeah,
that was great.
And Barcelona and what was the missing?
Midnight in Paris that was really good
to amazing.
Yeah.
We're owned,
Wilson actually plays Woody Allen.
Woody Allen impression.
Woody Allen got,
yeah,
it was interesting.
And that's where he joined.
Brodie was great.
He was playing Salvador Dali.
I am done Dolly.
Yeah,
he's,
look,
he's obviously really good at making
movies,
but you know,
we played some of stand up on the
podcast before.
Right.
And from like the 60s,
the early sixties and he was always a
pervert and early stand up.
It was like really pervy yes.
We'll look at sleeper.
There's a giant tip chasing him across
the park in central park.
This giant lactating tip,
50 feet up.
Quit.
This guy was a pervert.
He was a weird fucking guy.
I know.
Oh No,
no.
If,
ands or buts about it.
He was a weird fucking guy.
And he is a weird fucking guy.
Yes.
And,
and I guess what he's done is not a
crime because if you,
um,
if you look at the actual law,
he didn't do anything wrong.
It's not as biological daughter.
No.
You know,
you meet with soon.
Yeah.
So I guess he can kind of do that.
But then there's a thing that his
biological daughter says that he did
weird shit to her.
The problem with that is that he says
that his daughter was coached by the mom
and there's just no way to know.
I mean,
I know it would be horrible if you
accused him of sexually molesting his
daughter and was really just a
manipulation by the mother.
And that is entirely possible.
You don't know.
And there's this idea that you're never
supposed to judge someone who's making
an accusation.
He never supposed to question them.
They are the victim about.
And by that,
I think that's nonsense.
There's an incredibly large amount of
fake rape cases,
fake molestation cases.
These people lie about everything.
They lie about money,
they lie about sex,
they lie fuck by Frank Sinatra
married exactly till he turns out to be
old blue eyes.
Just that alone.
Just that you're like,
listen,
bitch,
you got a problem with the truth,
right?
Exactly.
Yeah.
That's the other side of it,
right?
She's not claiming there's taking that
crooner Dick while she was living with
woody.
I know she'd sneak off or a common just
going to go out and get a coffee and
just fucking toupee falls off.
Welcome to the club.
I gave you a kid.
All of a sudden he became dice.
Oh,
what a world diamond love.
Now.
It's very tricky.
I mean,
look,
if you're,
if your wife had any hint that something
was going on with you like crazy and
just like,
you know,
just please.
There's,
it's very complicated.
It's very sleek.
Did eventually leave her for the Suny
Mama?
What do we like?
Gossipers I just think,
no,
but it's money.
It isn't,
but it is kind of an interesting thing
because,
I mean,
if you were to what you said of like
that it represents other people that do
this as the kind of the swing thing,
because everybody,
if you didn't work with people because
of their private life and things you
didn't agree with,
you would never work with anybody.
Would you imagine?
They're a mess down
with them and go over their private
life.
Okay.
Have you ever lied to a cop?
Right,
right.
You know,
have you ever lied about speeding,
but have you ever not paid your taxes?
Now let's get into your sex life.
Do you ever think about other people
when you come?
Right.
Okay.
This meeting is over.
I had a buddy of mine that actually got
an argument like that with his
girlfriend.
She was like,
my friend says that guy's fantasize
about other women while they're having
sex with your girlfriend.
Is that true?
And he was like,
well,
sometimes she's like,
you fucking piece of shit.
She got really mad at him.
Right.
And I'm like,
I don't remember thinking about it.
Like,
why do you care?
I guess if your wife would just thinking
about just getting stuffed by some big
ass country football player,
some big dude with like chewing tobacco
in his mouth and fucking rebel flag hat
on.
He's just laying pipe on her and that's
what you're thinking about when you
fucker,
she's thinking about some corn Fred,
you know?
Imagine.
Right?
It'd be like,
ah fuck man.
But that's why you don't ask the
question.
That's why you don't ask.
You don't probably,
there probably is happening,
but you don't ask if,
if you really love your wife,
you want to know everything about her.
Nah,
you want to know everything.
She's just appointed.
Oh my God,
I love you honey.
But I hate that face you make when you
come.
You make me disgusted.
That's why I'm all fuck you.
He just walked into the kitchen in the
morning,
honey,
what are you thinking?
So next time you fucker just wear a
luchador mask or even better yet,
like I'll godzilla rubber Godzilla.
Hey fantasies are weird man because like
I can't,
I remember when I was in high school
there was a,
a guy who was writing for the Newton
south high school paper who wrote this
cool thing about the boy scouts.
And I remember reading this because I
was in the boy scouts briefly,
uh,
as a young teenager and they had,
you know,
the tenants like trustworthy,
loyal,
thrifty,
clean,
reverent and like one of the things
about what the voice boy scouts were
supposed to do is keep your mind pure,
right?
Keep your thoughts pure.
And this guy was like,
who wrote this article?
Obviously this is in high school in the
1980s.
Yeah,
Guy was pretty brilliant and he was
like,
I don't like the idea of anyone telling
me what I can and can't do with my
thoughts because sometimes my thoughts
are fun.
I like to explore the idea of,
of,
of thinking about these and his argument
in this newspaper and I'm like grossly
paraphrasing him cause again,
this is from 1982 or something like
that.
He was like,
you like you don't need to know what's
going on in my thoughts.
You just need you to know how I act.
That's how I act is important.
Not what I think.
So tell me to keep my thoughts pure.
He's like,
my thoughts are mine.
They're mine.
I do what I want with them.
That's right.
So if your girlfriend is just thinking
about that big country fucker,
I was like a piece of wheat coming out
of the corner of his mouth,
Tattoo on the back of his neck,
just laying dick.
God bless her fat Dick.
God bless her.
Whenever she's into like a sailor's
forearm.
I am not asking.
I mean don't you have moments like in
your relationship where you know you're
with each other for your life?
This is,
this is a long time thing.
I feel like we should meet and there's
no music.
There's times when you're all of a
sudden,
oh no,
no,
no.
This time he went to get some incredible
hulk walkaway music and there's times
when you were into her and that's it.
There's times when you know there's
times when all of a sudden you,
you,
you about to say there's times when
she's not in the EU.
Yes.
Unacceptable.
Walk.
Be a man.
Suck it up.
There's times when you were like,
you know what,
it not that psyched with me right now.
[inaudible] with a boner.
You chew to Viagra.
You get your Dick hard as a rock.
I'm not saying you don't do this thing.
What I'm saying is you don't ask her why
you don't ask what?
What is it like?
You don't want to know these things.
I don't want to know why she's unhappy.
I want to know.
I just want her to keep her thoughts to
herself.
If she's bang some big redneck and a
truck stop.
No,
you don't want,
I don't want to do,
you don't want to know if she's actually
bang or thinking about bang.
I don't want to know anything.
You don't want anything?
Oh No.
What a good husband.
You want her to just be a good mom,
a good wife and eat my bread.
And,
and how about she cooks something once
in a while.
Why am I baking bread like I'm an old
lady.
Why am I running around with a flower on
my shirt?
She's sitting on the couch.
You wear an apron?
No,
I have thought about it,
but I feel like it's going over.
Yeah.
What did you keep in the pocket?
I always wonder one head pocket.
Why?
Why is that even come up?
Well,
who throws shit and that front pocket,
I think it's useless.
A one hit and the razor blade.
A one hitter and a razor blade.
I never see anybody using that front
pocket on the Apron.
Yeah.
Never comes up.
No.
Well yeah.
What's in there?
Nothing.
You're lighter.
So it's cooked.
Show is go out and smoke a little.
Yeah,
they do smoke.
Which is interesting because cigarettes,
Dell,
your taste buds,
they don't care.
Food.
This is food.
Fuck God.
I don't eat in the shit.
But I always thought that was weird
about chefs because the whole idea about
preparing food is making something
that's delicious.
It's an art form,
right?
Yeah.
So,
but if you,
you're dulling,
it's like fucking with the condom.
It's like I'm really in a sec,
but I love condoms.
I don't know what to do.
I don't know.
I never smoke.
How much does it dead and your does it
really?
I don't never smoked either,
but allegedly it does.
Yeah.
The people that I've talked to that quit
smoking say that was one of the most
remarkable things about it.
Is it right after you quit smoking,
you get your taste buds back?
Eh Hm.
But you don't look as cool.
Hmm.
What is that about?
What's it about?
Something so stupid when you're sucking
on some burning leaves.
A prop.
A good prop though.
Like people that vape do not look cool.
They look like they've got a pacifier
sucking on a robot's Dick,
you know?
Well,
they have that box box ones.
Like how much batteries do you need?
How much you vape thing?
Give a fucking battery that can charge a
car and it glows like Rudolph and then
they blow the smoke clouds out like
fucking Christ.
What is this?
There's so much that comes out and they
get into it.
They get into the big giant clouds.
Yeah,
they do.
She sent me one and he sent me one that
I could literally kill someone with.
I could beat someone to death with it.
It's a big thick,
heavy copper one.
Do we still have that stupid thing
laying around tobacco or for weed?
It's for tobacco,
but you could use it for,
we'd definitely use,
we'd have yet like weed oil.
And it was,
it was a weird thing where you had to
like Ge drip the oil into this thing and
then we don't need to see a jamie.
It's okay.
Thank you though.
It was um,
but it was fucking heavy.
Like it probably weighed a pound,
right?
At least a pound.
Yeah.
For home use or you're not taking that
into the bar.
I supposed to just fucking carry it
around in a slang.
It looked like brass knuckles.
Yeah.
Really huge.
Fucking huge.
Now it didn't have a case.
It should,
should have a wheeler case so you can
take it through the airport.
That's not cool.
But cigarette to sit there with just the
cigarette in your hand.
It's a nudge.
A baby.
That stripe baby sending Mia.
You tell me.
I don't want to talk into that.
Jus the chairman of the boat has spoken.
It's the coolest.
It's a cool prop.
You can do stuff with it apparently can
make a point.
Yeah.
Apparently it's a really good cognitive
enhancer to oh yeah.
Yeah.
Nicotine is apparently,
um,
it's as effective as like a new tropic
as a co,
as a cognitive enhancer.
Like vitamins,
like Parasso tem and all these different
vitamins.
Coleen that had been shown to have
effects on memory and cognitive
function.
Nicotine apparently has a positive
effect on cognitive function.
I know a lot of guys who smoke like
e-cigarettes before they go on stage.
Really just to get a little,
a little buzz,
a little go coffee,
do the same thing.
I don't know.
I don't think coffee actually has a
cognitive enhancing performance benefits
that have been proven.
Just makes you busy,
makes you happier.
I know it increases euphoria and I think
it lights you up.
You like [inaudible] stimulates you.
So there's probably some benefit in
that.
Just being more awake.
If you are awake though,
I don't know if it really benefits you.
Like there's times when I'm writing and
like if I'm writing in the afternoon and
I'll have an espresso and they come back
and all of a sudden I'll catch myself
like 15 minutes later.
Like just humming along and like doing
studying,
you know,
like you just get busy.
You just get like,
all right,
we're going.
Yeah.
Without being aware that it was really
the caffeine.
Yeah.
Do you take the note?
What does it neurotropic nootropic
nootropics.
I'd take them.
You do?
I'm a big fan.
I want to take more stuff.
I really do.
I'm so into like,
I kept for a long time it was like I'm
not taking anything.
And uh,
now I'm at a point where it's like we
live in the 21st century.
It's time to start taking some stuff.
Like what kind of stuff?
I take vitamin D now.
That's good.
D Three d three yeah.
Very good.
Very important.
That's good,
right?
Yeah.
Well the only way you get it is through
the son or through certain foods.
It's particularly important for Vegans,
right?
Be 12 and [inaudible] are two of the
most common things.
Be 12 too.
Because it comes from
um,
you,
we get it primarily be 12 especially.
We get it primarily from an animal
protein and they apparently get it from
bacteria.
And the only way to vegans can get it is
in certain forms of bacteria.
Microorganisms like you have to eat
living things to get it.
All right,
so be 12 I should add also be 12 huge be
12 big a d three is tig,
three d,
h e a or not thca a Dha,
fish oil.
Oh really?
Fish oil,
Omega threes and sixes.
Super,
super important for brain function.
Omega,
Omega threes and sixes.
You take that as a supplement that yes,
I do.
You can get some of it from flax oil and
from hemp oil,
but it's not as effective as fish oil.
I mean,
this is taken out ideology and you know,
eating plants versus eating animals
scientist uniformly believe that fish
oil is the better method for absorbing
those things.
But then you go online and you look up
fish oil and there's just as much as
many articles.
The fish oil does nothing.
Well,
Omega threes and sixes are critical,
right?
That's what fish oil is.
We just know that from the official.
Yeah,
there's,
there's no doubt about that.
So someone's saying the fish oil does
nothing.
That's nonsense.
It's nonsense.
What does it do?
I mean,
here's,
here's the number one big deal.
People think that they like to take
things and then feeling an immediate
result.
And what you're doing when you're taking
vitamins and supplements and eating
healthy food is your building your body
with these,
these materials.
Like if you eat cake and Ho hos and
that's all you eat,
that's what your body uses to regenerate
cells.
That's where it,
your body uses to grow.
I mean all your tissue is eventually
going to be made out of everything you
eat of birthday deck,
birthing kit,
and then then sourdough bread.
So what we are today is your body's
consumption of all the different foods
and nutrients that you've taken in.
And this is what it's built with it.
And it can only make a good body off of
good ingredients.
It's,
it's really that simple.
If you're not getting any vitamins,
your body starts pulling them out of
your bones and your,
I mean,
pulling calcium out of your bones.
Right?
But your body freaks the fuck out when
you don't have enough stuff.
And that's where a lot of diseases,
inflammation,
a lot of problems come from just not
having the proper building blocks.
So,
right when you eat healthy,
you give your body what it needs to
rebuild and build.
Right.
So your growth from there on represents
your diet.
Like whatever you're putting in,
the healthier the stuff is,
the healthier your body is.
It's really simple,
but it's not going to be an immediate
effect I've had.
It would be pretty quick though.
Fairly quick.
You'll feel better and over time,
like weeks or months like this,
a wacky die that I'm on.
Initially it didn't feel good.
It didn't know there's lack of sugar.
Did not feel good.
Uh,
there's like headaches the first few
days.
Oh,
I'm addicted to sugar will,
I didn't even know.
And then forms of sugar,
like even just bread while you yeah,
for sure.
Right?
Yeah.
Bread,
even alcohol.
Um,
fruits,
you have to be careful even how much
fruit you eat.
Really?
Yeah.
Like,
like someone had a glass of orange juice
and they were talking about it.
They were like,
think about how many fucking oranges go
into the glass of orange juice.
It's probably like seven oranges.
Like really fuck sits down,
eats seven oranges.
And we were laughing and I was like,
yeah,
but not even with fiber.
Like you take the fiber out so your
body's like,
what is all this God damn sugar.
Right?
But we have it in our head that sugar
from fruit juice is healthy,
right?
Sugar from Coca Cola is not,
but apparently your body doesn't know
the difference.
But if you eat an apple,
isn't that just the fiber offset?
How much sugar?
It does have an impact.
It does.
So in a positive way,
your body's,
that's how your body's supposed to get
sugar,
right?
It's supposed to be attached almost like
as an incentive to eat things that are
healthy for you.
Right?
So the vitamins and the fiber or all
intertwined with this delicious flavor
that makes you attracted to it.
And therefore like you eat an orange is
in fact good for you.
Right?
So it's healthy.
You shouldn't eat,
go crazy with it.
Yeah.
You just shouldn't have 20 ounces of
orange juice is squeezed out.
Oh right.
And especially when we have that
concentrate stuff or it's not even
really orange juice anymore.
It's like this weird frozen thing.
Yeah.
But when you like with your kids in the
morning,
do you feel like you should give them
some orange juice if they're like
feeling kind of a vitamin C?
Well,
vitamin C's definitely good for your
body.
It's a good antioxidant and he signed
them run down.
I mean,
look,
it's not,
it's not the worst thing in the world.
Have a little orange juice.
What I'm saying is like a big ass glass
of orange juice as a jolt of sugar to
your system.
Or in the afternoon I preferred,
um,
I don't drink fruit juices anymore.
Yeah.
I just,
I eat,
but I still eat fruit.
I just think that juicing is very
problematic in that way.
That you could just figure out a way to
condense a,
all the sugar from all these different
fruits and one thing that you jolt into
your body and just a few seconds you
chug a glass of orange juice.
I mean,
that's,
yeah,
a tidal wave of sugar wall.
Um,
I take glucosamine.
That's good.
And Can Jordan,
do you take those two together?
Just glucosomine does are both really
good.
Glucosomines good.
Glucosomine was actually,
I think people might be wrong about
this.
This came from this book by this guy,
Doctor Joel Wallach who wrote this book
book called dead doctors don't lie.
And he was talking about mineral
deficiencies and um,
how few doctors really do understand
nutrition and how they give you a really
shitty advice,
but really they're completely
uneducated.
They might be a good podiatrist or a
good orthopedic surgeon or what have
you,
but how many of them actually understand
the mechanisms of nutrition?
That's where Doctor Rhonda Patrick comes
in.
She's a fucking genius when it comes to
that.
Like whenever I have any questions about
different nutrients or vitamins and will
just go over
the tasks and she's super analytical and
objective about it.
Right?
Like she'll tell you the pros and cons
and goods and bads and what you know,
what,
what could happen,
what could be going on and what is
definitely going on.
Right.
So there's,
you know,
there's a lot going on when you're
eating food.
There's a lot going on when you're
taking in nutrients and uh,
a Multivitamin,
I take a multi,
bless so many one multivitamin is
problematic too because you're taking
something that's condensed down to one
hard little cube.
Oh yeah.
And you're dropping down,
you're in,
you're hoping your body digests it and
time and absorbs it.
I find that powdered ones in capsule
form at least I think a absorbed better
in the body.
And I take a pack,
I take like pure athletes,
pure Pak,
writing it down.
Yeah.
It's pure.
Encapsulations is the brand that I use
and they have these athletes,
pure packs and I,
I just,
they're great because they're like a
meals worth.
I take them with me.
I can have like two or three in my
backpack and just pound it.
Yeah,
sure.
Well do you take this stuff too or do
you kind of a,
has it rubbed off on the amount of time
I've been hanging out with them.
I need to take advantage of it.
But uh,
yeah I just started taking some stuff.
Yeah,
you look good.
That microphone makes that sound.
What's going on with this?
Too much electricity over here.
You're a fucking Atlanta and you're
alive.
There's a lot of electricity going on
here.
Right?
Let's stop thinking about it when I
think we've heard my podcast when I use
like this little recorder and just no
reason.
This is a reason it sounds so shitty.
Vape pens we have in this room.
I know I have one of those.
So how many things do you take in the
morning?
Like 12 in the morning?
Um,
especially lately the morning I've
relaxed a lot of what I do as far as
like my diet cause in the morning a lot
of times I'm not hungry.
I'm out.
And I used to eat because I felt like it
had to eat,
but then I read this thing recently.
You know they,
they say that breakfast is your most
important meal.
Yeah.
Bullshit.
That's what I've heard.
It's bullshit.
What's important is meals,
right?
They say that breakfast is not your most
important meal.
That it's just a meal.
The idea of like loading up so you can
go on about your day is like it.
Sometimes it slows you down.
Yes.
And then the car bloating is what a lot
of people do.
They're eating cereal and that's just
going to cause a crash.
Right?
You ramp it up with the carb loading.
Your body has to process all that shit
and it's like,
whoa.
But a nice cup of coffee and some
sourdough toast.
That's what you do.
That's your move and once in a while and
you get to know him,
I had this fucking toast.
This is mine.
It's my goddamn comes from my made this
from my fan.
Yeah.
It's funny when I go on the road now,
that's the thing that they miss the
toast.
The bread really like you got to come
back.
You've been gone a week.
You're ah,
they,
they get upset that dad is not the
little bread factory.
It's cool because they used to miss me
for being a person and then they,
then that passed.
Now they want me for
my bread.
When you go on the road,
do you do just weekends or do you do,
do you ever do a tour?
I do weekends.
Let me,
sometimes it'll be,
I'll tag it with,
like if I go back east,
I'll tag something in New York like tv
or radio and then,
so I'll be gone for a week,
but I never go like city to city and I
come home.
I don't like my friend.
You Know Duncan Duncan trussell.
Yeah.
Dunkin's on a 30 day tour now.
Really?
You got a bus and everything so it's
traveling around the country.
Have a family?
Nope.
Yeah,
I've got a dog.
It's a different thing.
That's a different thing.
It says dog helps him.
Got One of those emotional,
a little licenses.
I call those the fake service dogs.
And you know those things.
Yeah.
What is it called?
An emotional needs dog.
Yeah,
you can have an emotional needs dog.
They bring them in restaurants.
It's so fun.
It's so fucked up because they violate
health coach saying,
I need my dog with me.
I know.
I saw the,
I was in New York.
That one was feeding a dog from a spoon
at the table,
like sneaking them food.
It's like,
how's this?
How's this?
Okay.
It's not okay.
I was just in a hotel in San Francisco,
people I'd,
they've given dog biscuits at the,
in the lobby and people you walk through
the hall,
there's dogs just barking their heads
off because dogs are allowed in hotels.
Well,
I love dogs.
I do too,
but you don't have to have,
I don't even mind dogs in hotels,
but dogs and restaurants like come on,
you ever been next to a dog that's
barking all night?
Because the parents are,
because the owners are out partying or
doing whatever they're doing and leave
the dog really and you're then they
should have someone come in,
euthanize it.
You shouldn't have even said that.
Right.
You're right.
Sometimes things come out and you don't
mean them to,
sometimes you mean them and you just
pretend that you don't.
If some dog next door is barking,
I would like to key to the room so I
could open it up and go,
dude,
it's going to be all right.
Relax I there's a biscuit.
Yeah,
you relaxed.
But this is why I'm,
I'm embracing the 21st century cause
I'm,
I am on the road.
I mean they'll all these weird places
and started to feel like run down and
stuff and I wasn't,
here's another thing is I wasn't eating
meat for a long time and I started
eating meat again and I feel so much
stronger.
I literally would be in the green room
like tired.
Like I'm like,
oh I am,
I am,
I'm not old.
Why am I tired to before a show at 10
o'clock?
And I really think I just wasn't getting
enough protein.
I really was just like eating salads in
between.
I just,
once I started kind of drifting back,
I interesting back.
Were you vegetarian or Vegan?
Vegetarian.
Well,
I would go back and forth but mostly
vegetarian.
So sometimes you were looking for like a
yeah.
For a whole year.
Yeah.
How'd that go?
Um,
it's,
you start talking,
you're sizing people.
It's hard.
I got very snotty.
Yeah.
I felt better than everyone.
Like I thought I was better than
everybody else.
I,
uh,
no,
it's very difficult thing to do.
Yeah.
You got to really make sure that you
monitor your protein correctly.
Like people say,
where do you get your protein from?
And they're like,
what are the,
what about this gorilla?
Listen,
bitch,
you're not a gorilla.
Okay.
You're not a fucking horse either.
Horses eat hay all day and they're fine.
Have giant muscles,
right?
Your body's different dummy.
Like people,
people need certain amounts of protein
and you certainly need a complex amino
acid profile and some proteins that
you're getting from plants.
They don't have a full amino acid
profile.
So if you're going to,
if you're going to go vegan and you want
to really make sure that your diet is
balanced,
you got to really do some reading.
Really pay attention to what I was good.
Chemo was really good.
Hemp is one of the best.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Hemp protein.
There's some stuff that we sell it on it
called hemp force protein powder and
it's one of the best ones because it's
super easy to digest a very fine
proteins.
It's a really expensive because I have
to get it from fucking Canada.
And it's one of the goofiest laws that
we have going today in this country that
you can't grow hemp still.
Yeah,
well some states are allowing it now and
it's eventually going to roll out and
it's going to be nationwide.
But it's,
it's one of the easiest things to grow.
It was like bamboo grows crazy.
It doesn't require nearly the amount of
a service that other plants do.
It's essentially it's a weed.
But,
um,
anyway,
the point is it's a full amino acid
profile profile.
Right.
And there's only a few plants that are
like that.
And then what other ones?
I just couple.
In all honesty,
I uh,
I was doing it for health.
I was doing it cause I have a lot of,
uh,
high cholesterol and heart stuff and my
family.
And I was like,
I didn't want to go on any drugs.
I'm just going to keep it at bay and I'm
going to eat clean.
And I ate that way for a long time.
And eventually just this last year,
my genetics kind of caught up to me and
it was like,
I'm eating this way and I still,
my cholesterol was high,
so I was like,
you know what,
I'm not going to go on a stat and then
lower it.
Yeah.
And a exercise I exercise.
What do you do?
I run and weights.
The reason why I ask this is Anthony
Bordain was on status and he got on stat
and it's just because his body was,
um,
he was,
you know,
constantly going on the road and
traveling and drinking and eating food
and his body wasn't responding well to
that.
He had real problems with blood pressure
and just decided,
well,
I can either restrict my diet,
which to him is offensive,
you know,
because he's a chef and it's a big part
of his thing.
And especially with his job,
he wants to get on the stat.
And so he got on the standards,
but then he got into Jujitsu,
got obsessed with Jujitsu,
lost 30 pounds,
got off the statens.
Yeah.
Now he's super healthy.
Well that's the thing.
I was,
I had high cholesterol and I said,
I'm not going to go on the statens.
So increased how I was working out.
I went Vegan for a long time and a
lowered it.
I was able to lower it and keep it at
bay doing that for a,
and he just started inching up,
starting to kind of coming back and uh,
I don't know.
So I just figured it's the 21st century,
let me,
and let me embrace the technology.
But there is a negative consequences
with your liver,
isn't that correct?
Well,
you have to be tested.
You have to be,
you have to stay on top of,
you got to do your blood work or is that
an issue?
I've only been on it for a couple
months,
mostly just randomly went on it.
Brand new.
Now have you ever thought about cutting
bread out and pasta and sugar?
Yes.
I've thought about it and I didn't like
what I was thinking while you eating a
sandwich.
Imagine if I couldn't have this.
The bread thing is really new,
like I wasn't eating a lot of red.
This is pretty new and I do love it.
The problem honestly is I grew up,
food is a celebration.
Food as a way to unite people.
Food.
It was a big Italian family.
Pasta was a part of it.
And uh,
I was like at eating as a Vegan.
I walked into who?
A Italian grocer in Burbank and the
Salamis and the pursuit or hanging from
the ceiling next to the provolone and
there's pastas and there's breads and
this gelato.
And I'm like,
my ancestors would just pummel me in
the,
in the alley if I was like,
I'm not eating this because I'm a Vegan.
And I'm like,
it's too much fun.
It's too much fun to celebrate and live
life and do the,
so if I could just do that once in a
while,
I can't say I'm going to be a vegan and
not eat that stuff for the rest of my
life.
Not going to do it.
Um,
of all the people that have ever
suggested healthy diets too,
no one looked at me more disgusted and
Artie Lange when already was in here and
he was talking to him about his,
yeah,
I gotta lose weight and he's talking
about this and I was talking to him
about cutting off pastas and breads and
all this,
and he looked at me like,
what the fuck are you saying?
He's like,
he was like offended.
Yeah.
Like in his eyes,
somehow or another he is going to
eventually figure out how to lose all
this weight without changing God damn
thing about his lifestyle or his diet.
But yet,
but that kind of thinking he's also why
he's so hilarious.
So funny.
You know,
he's just so wild.
Motherfucker.
While mother really devours everything
around them,
including gambling,
you ever talk to him about gambling?
I put 500 grand on this to when you put
what?
Hold on.
How long does it take you to make that
500,000
you had a $500,000
bet.
Oh my God.
Like I hear shit like that.
My palms start sweating.
I am terrified of gambling because I
know way too many people that do it and
rich people.
Oh yeah.
I know my friend Dana White,
who was the president of the UFC,
he's rich and he will gamble and he's
lost as much as a million dollars in a
night.
Wow.
Fuck that.
$1 million.
I wouldn't be able to sleep for a month.
No Way.
Getting the fuck out.
That'd be freaking
the fuck out.
It'd be like,
what am I doing?
Like what's wrong with me?
Yeah.
Well why is that worth it?
Like we won 7,000,001
night.
What exactly?
7 million.
7 million won it in one night.
I wonder if what?
How different the rushes winning $500 to
$7 million way different Tom Papa.
Really?
6 million.
995,000
can you go up to the,
can you go up to the guy like,
I want it now.
I'd like to take this with me now.
Well,
they don't like to pay you,
right?
Um,
because like they like to keep it in the
casino and million.
They paid him in garbage bags.
They wanted to give him cash.
They didn't even give him a bag.
He had to go and get garbage bags.
So they came back with those fucking
black hefty bags and they stuff $7
million in hefty bags and then left the
casino.
It said,
take it if you want it when you have $7
million in garbage bags and you're
leaving,
you're like
a small child with a sandwich walking
through a room full of wolves.
It's like maybe you'll make it to the
door.
Have these roles is just not going to
listen.
Like,
gee,
how many bags would that be?
I don't know.
If it's hundred dollar bills,
which I assume it is right there.
I know there are $1,000
bills.
Correct?
Have you ever seen one?
No.
I wonder who's on it.
Your mother.
Oh,
hey,
mama is a $5,000
there's a $500 bill.
Oh really?
Recently sold.
Someone hit it to trump and he signed it
or some shit.
Like,
really?
Huh?
Do you feel like you're deprived when
you eat this way?
No.
You don't feel deprived of anything?
No,
because nobody can seem
benefits are extreme.
Like physically I feel great.
So this is like the stuff that I just
drank the stuff in front of you.
This is a exogenous ketones because,
uh,
my body's essentially in a ketogenic
state.
So I take this mineral and amino acid
supplement.
It's called key genics.
What's a ketogenic state?
Ketogenic state means your body's
burning fat as opposed to burning
carbohydrates.
And one way to manipulate that state and
to make sure that your body stays cute.
Kid Keyed.
Atonic Ketotonic Kita Janice Ci
Ketogenic is,
um,
you take exogenous ketones and this
stuff allows your body to go back into a
state of Ketosis,
which means it's primarily using fat as
fuel versus using.
Meanwhile,
people right now are going,
will
you stop fucking talking about Jesus
Christ?
I'm interested.
Screws pop abroad folks.
I wouldn't have said it.
You all right?
Nothing happened.
We're good.
No.
Um,
I,
I'd like to eat lean.
I'd like to cut some of that stuff.
I don't eat that much bread shit buddy.
I'll do it.
You and Artie Lange get together and
come up with a diary.
I'll do it called the make-believe diet
plan.
Let's make believe
one day we're going to do something
different.
I don't feel different because I still
eat like really healthy and really
delicious foods.
How's this different from Atkins?
Atkins is mostly protein and the problem
when that is in does kind of put you in
a state of ketosis but that's not really
what your body wants.
Apparently your body wants more fats
than it does protein and there's huge
fattier.
Yeah,
but what I'm eating is like a lot of
Avocados,
a lot of coconut oil and a lot of things
along those lines.
Almond butter and when you eat a lot of
nuts and things like you're getting fats
that are healthy oils and fats that your
body processes really well.
The biggest benefit,
and this is something that my friend
Denny had said to me,
and this is thing I recognize too,
is cognitive.
Like I'm more awake really the day.
Yeah.
And I don't like the way I am right now
here at,
uh,
1220.
I'll be like this at seven o'clock at
night.
It's even through the day.
I was never even before man crash in the
afternoon,
I'd have these fucking meals.
Then I want to take a nap that's not
there anymore.
So after I eat,
when I eat,
like what I normally eat is like salads
with avocado and some sort of piece of
protein,
whether a piece of fish or chicken or
something like that or meet when I'd eat
like that,
I don't get tired.
Right.
It's just,
it's my body's telling me like,
look,
this is way more efficient.
It's way better for us.
And it's not like I'm eating fucking
cardboard and Tofu.
It's delicious food.
Yeah.
It's just no bread,
no pasta.
And what about your family?
They would ever the fuck they want two
weeks.
Sit down and eat dinner with them.
Yeah,
they do.
Well,
I just eat different stuff.
Like,
um,
one of the things that eat,
if we have pasta,
I eat squash,
I take squash,
Zucchini,
squash,
right.
And I run it through this machines,
like this thing that spins,
he cranked this handle and it Toros this
Zucchini through this cutter,
right?
That makes these little swirly pasta
like noodle things.
And then I put spaghetti sauce on that.
Really?
Yeah.
And your kids are like,
Dad,
what are you doing?
They don't mind.
They even eat some of it.
They're used to it.
My kids have eaten everything.
Right.
That's,
that's exactly what it is.
Oh,
that's right from my,
my page.
Um,
that's the,
uh,
see it twirls and into those noodles.
And then that's a ground venison.
So Joe,
if you had,
if you eat like this and then that one
meal you had pasta,
does that blow the whole thing?
No,
no,
no.
But it puts you out of,
it knocks you out of Ketosis.
But this stuff right here and knocks you
right back in.
So like even you could have like a
syrupy glass of soda and then have this
stuff and it'll put you right back into
ketosis.
It's just manipulating the way your body
processes fuel.
Right.
And I just find just for me that when my
boss and not just me like Shaw Brennan
Chubb,
my buddy who got on in a few months ago,
two months ago,
something like that,
he's lost a shitload of way.
He looks great.
Everybody I know that's done it loves
it.
Really?
Yeah.
I just don't think that your body's
meant to eat that much sugar in that
many process.
Carbohydrates.
I just don't think it is.
No,
they're not.
I'm going to do it.
You can do it.
That's even like with this bread,
it's like,
you know,
that was the only thing that you would,
that would be the carb that you would
eat.
You know what I mean?
You would have a little b.
The percentage in your diet was so
small.
Right.
You know,
then you were eating vegetables,
you're eating meats and fish and nuts,
salads,
folks eat some fucking salad.
It's so important.
That's one of the things that drives me
the most crazy about vegans.
Um,
one of the things is they'll assume that
you don't eat what they do.
Eat.
Like,
you know,
like Vegans,
like that guy was like telling me like,
I'm eating all these vegetables and I'm
getting all these nutrients and you're
not.
I go,
well actually I am because I mean all
those vegetables too,
right,
but also have steak,
right?
Like what the fuck are you to like this
idea that they're mutually exclusive.
It's so stupid.
Like,
yeah,
you definitely should have vegetables.
Everyone should eat vegetables.
But the idea that you shouldn't eat meat
because we're not designed for meat,
that who comes like an ideological
argument.
Then they start saying things like,
you know,
like the body was not designed for that.
Human beings are herbivores.
No,
no,
actually we're not.
It's not only that,
it's proof positive.
It's been proven that one of the main
reasons why the human brain got large is
because of meat consumption,
right?
Yeah.
I mean there's the monkeys figured out,
look,
there's,
there's better protein out there.
I started eating some,
whatever the fuck they did.
What did they
do?
You see?
They just found this walt whitman guide.
Someone found it in a,
uh,
in a library.
It was like this finding of a Walt
Whitman stuff that he wrote that people
hadn't seen before.
So they got excited.
It was about health.
It was about uh,
a guide to being a healthy man or
something in the first thing was eat
meat.
Of course that was his first thing.
Well that's what people thought back
then.
Yeah,
I mean it was,
there was
super important.
Did you see that thing recently?
They discovered the remains of a
mastodon that had been slaughtered by
people in,
I think they found it in Florida in a
bog or something like that or sink hole
and it was 14,000
years old.
So it threw a monkey wrench into the
timeline of people being in North
America because it pushed it back by
1500 years.
So it's like a new mystery as far like
they've really just,
there's a lot of just ramping
speculation once you get past a couple
of thousand years ago,
they're like,
who the fuck knows this?
There's like,
yeah,
there's current theories and they try to
work on them and they try to,
you know,
that they're trying to decipher the past
based on these little small clues that
they dig up here and there and
occasionally they dig up a new clue and
they just go,
whoa.
Okay.
All right everybody,
let's get together.
Let's get together because we'd just
fucked our timeline.
We've got to go back and rewrite the
whole timeline.
Yeah.
It's pretty cool looking though.
There it is.
Yeah.
They pulled it out and um,
a stone knife,
mastodon bones and a fossilized dung
found in an underwater case.
Scroll that down please.
Young Jamie.
A underwater sinkhole shows that humans
lived in north Florida about 14,500
years ago.
According to new research suggests the
colonization of the Americas was far
more complex than originally believed.
I love stuff like this cool learning
about mystery culture.
I'm just unbelievably fascinated by the
idea that people lived like us.
They were,
they were like us 14,000
years ago and they lived is crazy
existences where they were just hanging
together in these little tribes and they
relied on each other deeply and right.
And that was the only way you could
survive.
You had to get in these small groups of
like 50 people and everybody stuck
together,
had to gather food and everybody had a
responsibility.
And you know,
there's a direct connection between
social behaviors today and a hunter
gatherer,
um,
needs thousands and thousand,
excuse me,
thousands and thousands of years ago.
Like the reason why women are so
talkative and social and men prefer like
people being more stoic and men don't
like when men talk too much because
those men would fuck up hunting trips.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I mean if you were out there hunting in
those and the women would get together
and when women were gatherers,
women's jobs were equally as hard as
men,
if not harder because they were in
charge of farming like the men would
wear or gathering at least vegetables
and foods that you could find.
And then we'd go out and hunt hunt.
So the hunters learned how to prize
being stealthy and quiet and keeping
your shit together under pressure called
cool.
Yeah,
keeping your sh they're cool together.
When you're sneaking up on an animal and
all your nerves are firing in your
brain,
you have to execute a shot or throw a
spear and you have to get the job done.
Whereas women,
they get together and they start talking
about this one and that one and she says
this and I'm not picking the vegetables
sitting there by the river,
avoiding crocodiles,
washing underwear going,
that's fucking bitch thinks that she's
going to take mom or does your husband
come back from a Heinz and not talk?
I mean how can you be out for a whole
hunt and have nothing to say when you
come up.
My God,
I come home and I'm just Yap,
Yap,
Yap.
And he's like,
will you shut the fuck up?
I think I heard a stink snap stick.
Snap.
There's,
there's a line in the bushes,
honey.
I just got home.
I've been out hunting all day.
Just give me a minute before we start
talking.
I was watching this thing,
um,
the other night about the Mussai,
the Mussai warriors and I'm there mostly
herders,
you know,
they have all these cattle and it was
really crazy because they had like 10
year old kids helping out like these 10
year old kids are herding cattle and uh,
you know,
they're just doing jobs to work,
get to work.
Yeah.
10 and I'm,
one of the things they had this village
that is in the middle of this incredibly
wild area.
I mean,
there are surrounded by buffaloes and
lions and all around their village.
This is a very small little village,
which is really an extended family.
It's like the,
and the fathers and their families and
brothers and sisters and their families
and everyone lives together in this one
little extended village with all their
livestock,
but all around they're tiny village.
They had thorn bushes placed to keep
lions out.
That's their fence.
The fence is just making it
uncomfortable for lions to move in and
killed them with cheese.
So fucked man.
It was watching it.
And apparently that's not their biggest
danger.
Their biggest dangers.
Buffalo.
Oh yeah,
the air man.
Those,
those fucking Cape Buffalo,
I guess it is.
I don't know which buffalo there's,
that's what they look like.
Yeah.
On the buffalo now that's a baby.
That's a little tiny person.
Little tiny Mussai person.
Their buffalo are so weird there.
They look like they were close.
You have a row walking around naked.
It's cute,
cute little [inaudible] and they're
still survived today.
There's still assign.
Yeah.
So see those,
those bushes that they have set up like
that,
that's how they keep the lines out and
they just make it uncomfortable for
them.
They set up these smart parameters or
perimeters rather around their house.
But the Buffalo,
I guess it's a Cape Buffalo or water
buffalo or one of the buffaloes wa
Tanzania look up dangerous buffets.
Tanzania.
When are you going to Tanzania and the
August dude,
I'm thinking about going in August.
Are you really?
I'm thinking about going on the safari
with the family log on fifth through the
16th what are you doing?
Um,
I know a guy that runs these resorts
there and you're going to go safari,
the family.
Oh Shit,
Papa.
Maybe we'll be there at the same time.
We'll ignore each other though.
We can pretend we can meet.
We can meet in.
Pretend we're hunting for like a minute.
I gotta go back to my woman stuff for
bread.
What if they don't have bread?
Do you it right?
Yeah.
You gotta tell me where you're going.
We haven't decided yet.
We were deciding on a family trip to
summer and then delete it.
Be Europe or Africa.
Those are the two potential destinations
now and I haven't really,
I don't know.
Wouldn't it be cool?
This is mine.
I'm thinking I never really had a real
draw to Africa,
but the idea that I could get my
children to Africa,
it feels like a good thing.
I think those are willdabeast Jamie,
son of a bitch on those right down
there.
That one right there.
See that one right down there?
That guy is right in front of,
I guess that's a dead one,
Huh?
What is that?
That's some sort of a buffalo,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
That's a giant ass buffalo.
Yeah,
that's an enormous,
well those things,
apparently those buffaloes that they
have in,
um,
just find out what kind of buffalo,
because I keep saying buffalo.
There's a,
there's a name.
Um,
but those,
those things apparently are the most
dangerous thing in Africa.
Oh,
really?
Next to hippos.
Hippos are the most dangerous hippos.
Cape Buffalo or African Buffalo.
Okay,
so I was kind of right.
But those fuckers,
when I was watching the show on the
Mussai one,
one of the ladies had gone to get water
and she got jacked by Buffalo.
Really?
They just do to close.
They go,
fuck you.
And they just run out here.
They're like,
think of a bowl.
Like how mean bowls are fast.
Yeah.
I mean bull riders,
I mean,
those bowls or just a fuck you kicking
them off the gray.
I mean,
that's what these God damn things are.
But Times 10.
Oh man,
they're enormous about the hyenas.
That's what I'm worried about.
Dairy too.
Those things are evil.
They're all scary.
They're mean.
You know,
hyenas are one of the few animals where
the female is larger than the male to
keep the mail from eating the babies
railing,
you know?
Oh,
they don't give a shit to so main and
their jaws are super strong.
Yeah,
like some of the strongest bites in the
world.
I think only thing stronger.
It's like crocodiles on the safari.
Things you can't go out like you can't
go to the bathroom at night.
Is this the buffaloes?
Unless you have an arm,
you can read that.
What does it say,
buddy?
Oh,
okay.
Other than the big five,
it is known as the black death or widow
maker and is widely regarded as a very
dangerous animal.
It whoa.
It Gores and kills over 200 people every
year.
Jesus Christ buffaloes are sometimes
reported to kill people in Africa.
Kill more people in Africa than any
other animal.
You have a look at that picture of
Hemingway?
He just killed that fellow.
Some of the kink claims are made by
hippos and crocodiles.
My,
yeah,
you mean you can definitely kill them.
I'm totally killing it.
They don't taste good though.
My,
my problem would be with one of those
things.
Well,
you can absolutely eat buffalo.
Like a buddy of mine shot one with a bow
and Arrow,
but he said he was practicing with his
bone out for a half an hour while
chewing one piece of meat.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Like literally.
It's so tough.
I had buffalo this winter from,
uh,
yet bios don't area.
Oh,
that bison.
Yeah,
that was good.
Oh,
that's delicious.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a different kind of buffalo.
Well,
there's a real controversy and this
isn't a good quote.
Good thing to bring up now because I
found out something yesterday.
There's a big controversy that's going
on in yellowstone because they're
calling a large number of bison from
yellowstone and these people are
freaking out about it and they're
freaking out about it from a couple
different sides.
But one of the reasons why they say
they're killing them is because there's
a large population of them.
There's no hunting and yellowstone and
these animals are traveling to outside
of yellowstone and they're using the
land that ranchers used for cattle.
So like there's public land that
ranchers have rights to have their
cattle graze on,
but then these bison are intruding into
these land and they're saying that the
bison carry Brucellosis,
which is apparently a very dangerous
disease for cattle because it makes
their babies stillborn.
But there's no evidence apparently that
brucellosis is transferred from bison to
cattle.
See,
one of the guys that was on the twitter
exchange that I was having last night
was explaining that and a,
and I said,
really?
I said,
well,
why are they killing these animals the
same that they have brucellosis and
they're worried about,
I'm transferring it to cattle,
no evidence that they've done it.
So I go and look at it and apparently
it's true,
apparently elk or more likely to
transfer brucellosis to cattle,
but elk don't use the same grazing
ground.
They don't,
they don't graze the same way that
cattle do.
So with these buffalo do is they just,
they're competing for grazing ground and
they're using the brucellosis as an
excuse to slaughter them.
And so they're just going in there and
shooting them and they use all the meat.
I mean they're bringing all the meat
too.
I mean,
it all becomes either gets donated to
native Americans or they butcher it and
sell it,
so you're allowed to shoot them.
There's,
they're allowing a call of a certain
amount of it,
but apparently it's hundreds of them and
you know people that love seeing those
things at yellowstone or kind of
freaking out because they're doing it
because of cattle operations.
Really.
It's really,
it's really a thinly disguised like
protection of cattle land.
It's a strange thing because you bring
them back and they get to a certain
number and then that number becomes too
large,
but too large for what,
two large in large for a very small
area,
right?
Yeah.
For the way that the humans are living.
Like you know in New Jersey they have
this,
there's so many deer you want to shoot
more deer,
but it's because it's the most densely
populated state in the union.
There's just,
well,
they don't have a predator.
That's the real problem in deer.
Right.
With dear,
dear require a prey Predator balance
that we have in California.
Like California has a weird thing going
on and it's,
I like it in some ways.
In other ways I don't like it.
One of the things that I do like it is,
and what California has done is allowed
mountain lions to kill the deer.
Right?
And you can't kill mountain lions.
So there's no,
there's no hunting of mountain.
That's one of the few states,
one of the few states that has a large
healthy mountain lion population.
Hunting's not,
not regulated.
So the problem is wildlife biologists
don't agree with that.
Wildlife biologist thinks that you have
to manage the numbers of mountain lions
just like you manage all the other
animals.
But on the flip side,
because you don't hunt mountain lions,
you see very little deer.
It's very hard to find like deer
hunting.
And California is diminished radically
since the 1990s when they instituted
this.
No mountain lion hunting.
So the mountain lions are just eating
them up.
They're going like crazy.
And there's a lot of mountain lions.
There's a lot.
There's a friend of mine who is a um,
uh,
he works on a ranch called to hone ranch
and to hone ranch has this one waterhole
where they have a camera set up to
photograph whatever animals in there.
They found 16 different mountain lions
on one waterhole.
Choose Jesus Christ.
Really create those breezeways like over
the freeways and stuff.
Well they're trying to do that.
I don't know if they have actually done
that.
We actually built it where I've seen
him.
Uh,
I think on the way back from palm
springs I didn't go on help jog and I'm
one of those things.
Yeah.
Have you ever seen that video of the
lady in Florida?
Well she's on like a,
like a small bridge.
A Panther runs
buyer?
No,
I've never seen it.
Oh my God.
It is a shit.
Your pants and a half moment cause it's
big man.
Really big.
Yeah.
Both the Florida panthers and other
animal that was like on the brink of
extinction and it's the same animal.
It's a mountain line.
Ooma Puma Panther,
Mountain Lion.
Same animal.
Just different colors.
No,
not even different colors.
This one is mount line color outfits.
Yes.
They have different nail Polish and
stuff,
but this,
uh,
watch this video.
Look at this.
This lady's on this bridge.
Check this shit out.
It's crazy.
We'll hear it.
Give us some volume in.
Jamey.
Look at this.
So she's hanging out.
She's walking on this bridge.
She's like,
look,
everything was so pretty.
Oh my God.
What?
No,
he just wasn't interested.
What?
Thank God.
What in the first,
a big cat too.
Yeah.
It's wooden bridge and the everglades,
I think it is.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
He got scared.
He was just a scared.
Do you see that?
This Christ you were talking about,
I'm out here and they showed a guy who
was working on in someone's house?
Yeah,
like in the Hollywood hills and the guy
just comes out and he's like doing the
plumbing or something.
He's like,
ah,
there's something in there.
It's really big that just put like a
flashlight on this giant stick and deep
under the house.
That's where that was his den.
Oh,
mark.
This is living in,
they're living under his house.
Yeah.
There's another video that I posted
yesterday,
Jamie,
or this guy.
We're a bear.
A fucking huge bear comes running at him
full clip and the guy jumps up and down
and screamed at the top of his lungs and
it turns around and bolts real.
Yeah,
but twitter.
it's on my twitter.
But like last minute got like as close
as Jamie is to you.
Grisly.
Huge.
G huge.
I mean like 700 pounds.
It is a fucking enormous.
This bear.
Look how big this barris like,
wait,
wait to see this video.
You're going to shit your pants.
So it goes go fullscreen Jamie.
It's not going full screen.
Yeah,
there you go.
Wait,
you're going to shit your pants do
Swedish man.
So this guy,
he sees it in the woods and it starts
running up to him.
Where's the volume buddy?
It's all wintery.
Okay.
Why is no sound?
It was definitely sound.
We got to hear the sound because the guy
screams at it.
Hold on.
We've got to figure it out.
Wow.
It worked.
Holy Shit.
I never saw it.
I never even thought that would work.
Huh?
What's that?
Well,
it's definitely got sound,
so let's figure it out because you've
got to hear it because the guy goes,
ah,
well look,
I'll put his arms out to the side.
Look at the size of it.
It's running at him,
like running at him and he was able to
scare it.
He reels back like he's scared.
Well he went for,
you know,
look,
look
the bears like,
Oh shit,
look it up.
Look how big he is and look how much
bigger that thing.
It's like four times,
five times bigger than him.
Oh my God.
That makes me freak out.
If he had turned and Ronnie would have
been eating.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
I mean the thing ran at him like it was
dinnertime.
I was that close to a bear.
Where in Alaska and Denali.
Jesus.
A bar.
A grizzly.
Yup.
What the big ass grizzly.
We woke up in the morning and,
uh,
we were in back country for a couple of
weeks just hiking and walking around.
And um,
we got,
we woke up and we were making our
breakfast and we look up on a ridge and
there's this big ass bear.
This is September,
so it's like late,
you know,
it's like they were getting ready to
hibernate and he's walking down the
ridge and as we're packing up and uh,
you know,
you're up to the ridge is actually where
we were cleaning our dishes and doing
all this stuff and now we're back at
camp,
were breaking down to hike out and we
see this thing go walking down and just
dumb asses.
We're so lucky we didn't get eaten.
The Guy,
uh,
we pack up and we just start walking in
the same direction that the bear was
going,
where like,
he's not going to be going.
He probably has beaten us there.
So we're walking through these,
these reads,
these like bamboo kind of little reads,
but there were only like six feet high
and there's like eight of us,
maybe six of us.
And we're walking with our packs on and
you just hear and you see the reeds
separating you slowly though.
Like it's not coming fast.
Just I'm like,
what the hell?
That's probably the bear.
We see that it's the bear and you know
you're supposed to do what that guy did
and put your arms up or at least freeze
and don't.
Everyone in the group took off.
That's the one that ran and all frozen
in the pose and me and my one friend
like you're not supposed to do the run
and we're in our,
and then they take off with their
backpack.
Oh my God.
But the bear,
thankfully just by a stroke of luck,
this thing was so fat and tired and the
end of September he just wanted to go
down low,
get some more berries and just take a
snooze was not interested in us at all.
He was just so lucky,
so lucky.
But I swear to God it was from me to the
end of this table.
Yet.
When they're gathering up berries,
that's when your safest,
they get in their head that that's what
they want to eat and eat a lot of
berries,
right?
Oh,
he did not.
He was not interested to fuck all of
that.
So close animals.
I said No.
I mean,
I love the the there.
I think it's cool,
but God dammit,
they scare the shit out of me.
He's a a video of these guys.
They're hanging out by this river and
they have like a little lawn chair and
this bear is enormous.
Grizzly
bear just walks up and sits down next to
them.
Have you seen that one Jamie?
Close encounter with grit?
Grizzly bear casually walks up to people
and they just had a talk to them.
They're like,
hey man,
get the fuck Outta here.
And the bear just gets up and leaves.
But I mean,
he's like a school bus.
Yeah,
it's so minivan.
I always describe it like a minivan.
Did you find one?
Yeah.
This is it.
Look at this.
Wow.
Look at the size of this.
It just sat next to his chair.
Just pulls up to his chair.
Ah,
beautiful animal.
They'll look at that thing.
Oh my,
there's the gorgeous with Dex to do.
If that's you,
um,
you can't do shit.
Can't do shit because like you,
you don't want to provoke it.
No,
no,
you definitely don't want to back up
that thing.
He's just chasing salmon right now.
Yeah.
You don't want to yell at it.
As long as you don't hit it doesn't
think you're a threat.
They're really dumb.
Right.
In their mind,
ma'am.
Not that I'm like,
no,
I mean like,
like dumb.
Like if they were a person,
they'd be retarded.
Right,
right.
Okay.
The syllable,
there's simple.
They're predators,
you know,
they get in their head like what they
want to do.
Oh my God,
he's just sitting down.
This is awesome.
Just decided chill.
What a clear shot.
Well,
they'll look at is huge.
Look at his claws.
Yeah.
One Swipe.
I mean,
your face is off.
The guys filming this is 10 feet away
from him.
He's right there and the eventually
talks to him.
He's like,
Hey,
get outta here.
Like the bear looks at him and like,
we really,
you,
hey,
look how close it is.
The bear looks like a little annoyed for
a second.
Do the thing.
Just wandered towards him.
Seriously.
God,
they're everywhere.
Oh my God.
Now I don't even feel bad for that guy
back that up,
like watch or they go to the river.
This guy's sitting with a lawn chair by
the river while one,
two,
let's see,
three,
four,
five,
six and that one says,
oh my God.
Oh my God,
there's a dozen.
Bears is a dozen.
Massive grizzly bears seen it.
Oh my God,
I'm so scared.
Oh my God.
There's more.
Look at those other two.
One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine,
10,
11.
God,
how funny.
If you hold back in the guy with the
camera as a bear.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
That's amazing.
Oh my God.
They're the coolest animal.
That's my favorite animal.
Dan.
Cool.
Until they're eating you.
Yeah,
and not so cool.
No.
Yeah,
they're,
it's so at.
They are so cool to look at it when they
get up and they're just,
ah,
have you ever eaten bear?
No.
It's good.
Brown bear is not so good.
Like those are not so good because they
mostly,
they're mostly predators,
but black bear.
Yeah,
they eat a lot of berries and like
little strat.
It's traditional like hunters have been
bear forever.
I thought like when people want to hunt
bear I,
before I became a hunter,
I was like,
why would you want to shoot a bear?
That's kind of stupid.
That's like a,
it's gross.
He's like,
why?
I thought of it like trophy hunting.
Like someone who goes out and kills a
rhino or something like that.
Like,
oh,
why are you doing that man?
You just doing that to stuff,
that thing or something.
Yeah.
But no,
they eat them and who turns trying to
trying to bear hunting.
My friend Cameron Hanes is a bow hunter.
Oh yeah.
He's like,
he's like,
they taste good,
don't listen to anybody.
And he was like,
everybody has this idea in their head
that you don't eat them.
And he goes,
that's not true.
Up in Canada in particular,
like where we hunt.
It's traditional.
Every year people go out hunting bear
and a Alberta.
They're delicious man.
The way I described it as like a deer in
a pig,
it's like a combination of deer and
pigs.
Deer and pig.
Yeah.
It's an interesting,
it's almost kind of like kind of a beefy
flavor.
They make roasts out of foam and all
these different things and they have to
keep the population down because they
don't have any predators,
so there's massive numbers of them and
they slaughtered the moose and the deer
and so well up there who pries moose and
deer,
which is like really important for their
food.
That's most of what they eat,
right?
Yeah.
I've heard of people having Mousse.
I never heard of people having bear.
Yeah.
It was a lot of bear hunting.
A lot of a spring and fall.
Bear hunting apparently falls the best
because when they eat berries,
when they,
especially blueberries,
they actually get a blueberry tint to
their fat and their meat smells sweet.
Oh,
interesting.
Well that's really weird.
But your body,
like those grizzlies are bad to eat
because their eating raw fish and rotten
fish all the time.
The carcasses.
Like if you need a bear that's been
eating like a dead Moose,
like of a moose gets killed and just eat
the carcass there.
That's tastes terrible.
So like you,
you are what you eat and you can apply
that to yourself.
Like your body literally is built up as
we were talking about earlier of the
nutrients that you put in at the food
that you put it in your dietary choices.
That's the same thing with bears.
So these black bears that are living up
there,
they're mostly eating.
Look,
when they get a chance,
they eat a lot of fawns like deer fawns
and um,
calves,
Moose calves.
And occasionally that can eat an actual
dear like of a deer,
breaks its leg or fucks up.
Most of the time,
deer can get away when they're full
grown,
but the,
the ones that need the berries,
they're delicious.
And this is like a Jesus Christ set.
The same guy that's a picture from the
place I looked it up.
It's called the Mcneil's state thinks
she wearing and Alaska.
Oh my God.
One is apparently ever died there,
but all these bears come in for three
months.
They gather and just gorge on Salmon,
so they're not even looking for that.
Oh,
okay.
That's amazing.
That's one of the cool things about
those bears.
Yeah.
They're in those situations like they
just have it in their head like,
okay,
we're just eating fish now.
I'm eating fish.
I don't get how many of them there are.
That's amazing.
We're looking at a photograph and Jamie,
where'd you find this photo?
It just googled mcneil animals are,
so there's,
in this image,
there's three,
four,
five,
six,
78910111213 1415 61718192212 I shoot
2124 25 bears just in this one photo.
She's,
and they're giant.
That is giant grizzlies.
Kodiak is the weirdest place man,
because Kodiak is an island,
but it has the biggest brown bears in
the world.
Does the brown bears,
brown bears and grizzlies are the same
thing was Kodiak?
No,
he bought it in Alaska.
He bought in a place called the grizzly
maze,
which is a,
a,
a place where,
what does he eat?
And they're dumb place to go.
Is that a fish?
Yeah.
Fish like crab,
but um,
google the giant bears of Kodiak because
they're the most enormous grizzly bears
or brown bears rather in the world when
they're on the coast,
they call them brown bears when they're
interior that calm grizzly bears.
That's the difference.
It's the same exact animal.
That's a dead one.
Look at the size of that thing that's
mad.
Oh,
what the fuck band does that affect?
I think that's a trained bear actually.
Yeah,
the guy,
I see the guy and I think that's a
trained bear.
I think that's like a movie bear.
Look at that one down there.
Look at that one right where I pulled
out with the guy standing there with a
rifle above and to the right above and
to the right.
Right.
That's okay.
Yeah.
Look at that.
What the fuck?
We're going to have feet with the size
of the biggest feeder and you know
what's crazy?
There was a bear that was way bigger
than that called the short face bear
that we were,
we brought up the other day that was
apparently the most fearsome Predator in
North America up until like 11,000
years ago.
She,
the thing running that is so wild.
It's so crazy that this being exists.
I know,
you know,
because if you,
if you didn't have bears,
if they weren't real and then it was in
a movie,
you'd be like a,
if those things were running around,
but they really are running around and
we just get so used to them.
When you hike in the back country like
that,
you have to put all your food in these
containers,
these black container and hang on first.
Yeah.
The first time I did it I was like,
I had all this food.
And it's like,
oh,
so you just put it in a bag and you hang
it up there.
They're like,
no,
you put it in these cylinders sealed off
and then you put them,
you can eat.
You don't even have to hang them.
You can just get them out of the way
cause they're just completely sealed.
Right.
But the amount of food you can fit in
that is like you'd have to bring all
packs of stuff.
It's like has to be so small,
you have to live so small because they
just come and sometimes you're in your
tent and you just hear Oh oh well they
have,
I'm dehydrated food and freeze dried
food and freeze dried food is you just
add hot water to but dehydrated gets
really,
really small so you can pack a lot of
food into a very small area.
You just have to figure out how to add
water to it.
It's got to be me like I haven't done
it.
And probably 12 years,
the amount of improvement that must have
gone on in those 12 years.
It's gotta be my on the food.
Yeah.
Just going into the camping section must
be like a whole futuristic thing now.
I think the big improvement is
dehydration,
um,
versus freeze drying.
I think that as far as like space,
how much space that you save.
So when you see a bear and you're there
with your little bow and Arrow,
no,
you're fucked.
Are you a not good?
Are you scared?
Oh yeah,
for sure,
man.
Yeah.
If you see bears,
you should be fucking nervous as shit.
I mean,
most likely they're not going to come
get you,
but they might if you miss,
like if you hit it and it's knee,
will he be pissed and come get you?
Perhaps most likely they were going
away.
Right?
Most likely.
Um,
I know a guy who knows a guy who's
friend was attack as were many,
several steps removed.
It's,
I know it's a good story.
The first hunting trip ever,
I think they were hunting for deer.
He's in his tent and he gets mauled in
his tent by a 500 pound predatory black
bear.
500 pounds,
500 gum that black.
Oh,
they get bigger than that.
Do they really?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I thought black bear where like the
small bear into the know,
sometimes small,
but that's when they're juvenile.
Like they have a hard scrabble life man.
Most of them get eaten as cubs rather.
Bears.
Bears are cannibals.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Especially Blackburn's.
Oh yeah.
Well,
brown bears too,
but,
but black bears get enormous.
A friend of mine just killed one that
was eight and a half feet tall.
Cheese.
Yeah.
Look at this picture.
I'm gonna show you a picture and you're
going to go,
what?
Lydia?
Size that.
That's black bear.
Well,
it's big.
Eight and a half feet wide.
Eight foot,
three inches.
So you,
you're deep in the woods.
You kill this thing.
Hey,
get it out of there.
Well,
you got to cut it up.
Cut it up and pack it out.
Yeah,
you have to.
There's no other way,
unless you have a large suv or something
that you can drag it into,
but you're walking in.
Yeah.
If you're walking in,
you're going to have to pack that out.
She's didn't take his head.
They take you.
Take everything.
Take it all.
Yeah.
If you're going to kill an animal,
I think you should take everything.
Right.
You should take all the meat for sure.
And like these skulls that you see,
like that deer,
the deer,
moose,
and the deer over there and the elk
that's out there,
those are all a mean,
right?
Those are,
that's,
it becomes like,
I don't want to say a decoration because
it's way more powerful than that.
Like if I had to choose like anything to
keep in this room,
it would be the skulls.
Like regular,
like you could take a couple of things
in this room.
Everything else has to go.
I'm like,
I'm not letting these skulls go to
waste.
It's just,
they mean it means too much as far as
like,
right.
There's a spiritual level too.
It's a connection.
It's like these animals there.
Uh,
there's a bunch of things that happens.
You eat them,
you,
you shoot them,
you eat them,
they become food.
You have friends over I give,
I'm going to give you some elk when you
leave.
Give you some ground.
Yeah.
I've got a whole freezer back there for
really?
Yeah.
It's delicious.
You'll love it.
Can you dunk your bread in it?
He can make elk burgers with your sour
dough bread.
But it's,
I feel like there's a responsibility.
You're the caretaker of their skulls,
if that makes any sense.
Does it right when Vegan shoot
themselves?
Like,
I can't take this anymore.
The other jammer,
biggest black bear.
Oh,
they found out,
wait up to 900 pounds.
They think,
oh,
mom is constantly does size of that
fucking thing.
Bear expert.
Jeff Trask,
US saw Ted and Ted's lifelong Wisconsin
home an estimated him at over 900
pounds.
Ted then went into hibernation,
lost weight over winter,
20% loss,
18 120 pounds.
Bup,
bup about Ted arrived here at the North
American bear center in 2007.
It's still at a huge belly.
Uh,
he weighed 860 pounds,
so they captured him.
Is that what happened?
She wasn't there.
A real popular band that just got shot
in yellowstone.
Yeah.
He got shot outside of yellowstone by a
poacher.
It was a poacher.
Yeah.
It was a bear that was dying already
anyway,
had lost 50% of his body weight.
He was all scarred up.
He was like,
people knew him.
Like legendary bear.
Yeah.
He apparently had scars all over him.
That's how he could tell what he looked
like from fighting with other bears,
his face.
It's just ripped apart.
A lot of marriage,
love and marriage.
Marriage get you shine bucks.
You and Polanski can hit the skids.
That's another thing I'm doing this
summer.
I'm going to yellowstone.
I haven't been yellowstone since I was a
kid.
Oh Man.
Go on.
I can't wait.
I want,
I hope we see some wolves.
That'd be the coolest shit ever.
It's the coolest.
Yeah.
I saw wolves,
Moose and Bison.
When did you go?
Uh,
when my wife and I were dating first
started dating,
which would be 18 years ago now.
Now on a motorcycle.
Wow.
You went to yellowstone.
Him,
you fucking rebel.
Cross country for five weeks.
Wild ass professional comedian.
You must have killed her.
I found a real man,
wild man with a motorcycle.
Once a fucking go chase down a moose.
I don't want to stay here.
Let's go to the days inn.
That was me,
not her.
And she want a camp on top of a rock,
but we can't.
Uh,
we did a lot of days.
It was across the country.
We were,
when we got to the tetons in
yellowstone,
we camped and man in the tent and
looking across this field at just bison
like early morning,
like 5:00
AM just watching bison do their thing
and you're just,
you just woke up there too.
It's amazing.
You know what's so cool about that?
That that park is essentially the same
way it was a hundred years ago.
Amazing gear.
You're sitting there and these animals
are living.
Look at that.
It's near old faithful.
Oh,
it's the greatest.
What?
Amazing animals bisons are incredible.
I mean just,
they don't even look real.
What?
They're crazy beards and big stupid
heads and their high heels.
Yeah.
Right?
Like if you're going to have an animal
that
big,
why did it have feet?
So little little dainty girl,
fake Chinese foot binding and shit for a
giant biceps.
He's got a felonious munk t what is it?
Why is the color of that ground,
Jamie?
Why is it so orange like that?
Yeah,
but go back to that picture,
right?
Is that what it is?
Probably.
God.
It's so beautiful.
That's so crazy.
Looking at,
Oh,
it's the craziest,
crazy that that is a volcano that just
has like a leaky spot.
It's so amazing.
I went when I was like,
and there are lesser geysers as you go
around,
you know,
not just faith,
but it's a giant volcano.
They have something like 2000
earthquakes a year there.
Maybe even more.
Oh,
we have this little baby ones.
Is that a wolf?
That's a wolf that that population came
roaring back to.
Well,
they really successful.
Accessible.
They brought them back.
It wasn't,
um,
it wasn't that they came back.
They brought wolves from North America.
From Canada rather.
They're different.
Oh,
they are here.
They're larger.
They're larger wolves.
Larger Grey Wolf's from North America,
from North America.
Keeps saying that from Canada.
We get that little cute fucker.
We'll see guy.
Is that a white talking about me fellas?
What is he a weasel,
but I'm a big guy too.
Cute.
Hey,
look at me.
Hey fucker.
Fucker.
You got a sandwich for me?
That's a white weasel guy.
He's so adorable.
Yeah.
Take a look at me.
What a little,
isn't it funny that's a little murderer,
right?
Exactly.
Scavenger if our rabbits,
he's dad.
He's like,
fuck,
fuck.
What the hell are you doing?
Ferris are illegal in California,
but pitbulls are fuck the bears.
Come hang out with me.
I said,
what can it be in this lot?
I don't even know were alive.
They're practically retarded.
There was a fully a cute little bear
cub.
There was a photo that I had on my
instagram page of a bear with a
groundhog in its mouth,
like completely in its mouth.
We just like the feet are poking out at
the,
they were like,
oh,
these fucking things are so big.
They're just eating machines,
man.
This is all day.
You know,
it's my new animal who,
uh,
I saw a documentary bears in my main
animal,
but uh,
this year's animal is the beaver
beavers.
Cool.
Holy Cow.
Those things are amazing.
Weird fucking animal too,
Huh?
Weird.
A weird ass tail.
Just going to work.
Nasty ass buck teeth changing river
flows.
They put these stuck some beavers in
Nevada and they brought back a whole
region.
They manage the water.
They do some weird shit,
man.
They all have a weird place.
That's one of the coolest things about
nature's.
He's weird places that every hat every
animal has in the system.
These things are amazing.
They just go in and
just go to town.
They changed the whole bottom of the,
of the lake and the river.
They just take all of the wood and they
stick with their family.
They're very family oriented animals.
What a strange animal that like
regularly choose down trees and build
structures.
Just constant.
What other animals like that?
None.
Sorry.
Nine just goes to work with his face but
hasn't know.
How's he known to chop down that tree?
That's what he does.
I'm a beaver fever.
I chew what asshole.
Saw that and thought that's be a good
nickname for a pussy.
Right?
Exactly.
And then we see a beaver.
Beaver.
What is your,
what is all going on within that?
There was was one,
so I can't look shit up with your kids.
Oh,
that's not the kind of beaver were
looking for hunting.
If I had to pick one animal that I could
see in the,
in the woods,
like accidentally say like wandering
around.
I think it'd be a Wolverine Wolverine
just to see them like apparently they're
really rare to see.
Apparently you could like be like a
woodsmen woods and never see her woods
woman a woodsman for many years.
I'd like to be an admin.
What'd Ya get bored after awhile.
Yeah.
He smelled to share.
You could shower or bathe in the river.
He had don't go down the stream.
You're not doing wolverine.
That's a wolverine.
You don't want to see that for it.
Yeah,
he did.
They don't really,
they're like,
what in the fuck?
Look at his face.
No,
they're in America.
What for?
Yeah,
for sure.
Like in Yosemite.
Oh,
Karen tead.
They have some wolverines out there.
Oh,
look at that.
Look at those teeth.
Ferocious little animal.
No big as that.
They get that big,
I think they're like 50 pounds or so.
Oh,
the biggest asshole kid.
Jesus fucking Christ kid.
Oh,
it's on a way.
She's on a leash.
Wolverine on a leash.
I don't want to see that.
It looks gross.
Oh two based.
It's got like a sloth body.
Come on,
look at this one.
Messed up his face.
Got a couple of them that he's holding
onto the road.
There was a door.
I don't like him.
You don't know during the weasel family
apparently.
I like a nice beaver.
A Nice laid back guy.
He's got a tail.
He little teeth.
He goes to work.
He can't really talk to you.
He's working on this.
His projects.
You prefer the animals are
nonthreatening?
No,
but I love the bear.
The bear is my main animal.
I think wolves too.
I think wolf would be like,
if I could see a pack of wolf take out,
like take out a deer.
I think that'd be cool.
Shit.
This is why we got to go to Africa.
We're going to see so much shit.
Whoa.
We're going to see a lot of stuff.
You think a lot of stuff.
We can say everything.
Eating everything.
It's going to be lions,
eating bears,
eating zebras,
no bears.
There's going to be lions eating zebras.
It's going to be giraffes being ripped
apart.
This has got to put everything in
perspective.
How long is the flight going through
Amsterdam from New York?
I'm going to go to New York first,
then I'm going to go from there to
Amsterdam,
to Tanzania,
and that's
I think a 16 hour ordeal.
So it's live to stop though from La to
what does this Jamie led in New York is
fine.
Oh my God.
Again,
chased by a giraffe.
Look at the girl's face.
She's fucking panicking.
Holy Shit.
There really aren't getting chased.
Yeah,
that's legit.
It's not gonna be.
What do they do when they catch up to
you?
They spit on you.
They licked the swing.
Their heads like a,
like a weapon.
Swinging it at me.
I'll knock you the fuck out.
Oh,
totally.
I'm riding one of those things,
so I keep telling my kids I am writing a
giraffe like,
dad,
you can't ride giraffes.
Don't try.
You can.
You can do it.
I'm going to do it.
That's especially wild ones.
Mom,
did they really argue with that?
So we keep it going.
I haven't pictured,
we were at the San Diego Zoo recently or
the Santa Barbara Zoo and I'm,
it's a good one.
They drafts are one of the few animals.
I actually had a bit about this in my
act.
The one of the few animals that I think
are better off in captivity because they
don't,
they don't give a fuck like other
animals,
like so sad,
but giraffes another day with no lions
and they just wander around like they
don't seem to mind at all.
Like their behavior,
their behavior is so predictable that
they let babies feed them or hold up a
piece of leaf and a baby will come over
and take it from the draft will come
over and take it from the baby.
No,
they're just,
they're just really chilled out animals.
But here's the other thing,
but they,
they're fucking mean to other drafts.
They fight to the death.
They beat the shit out of each other
with those lumps on the top of their
heads,
swing it.
And one of the other things they do,
they keep food away from younger
giraffes.
And the way they do it as they eat all
the low hanging leaves and they do it to
try to purposely starve out other
giraffes.
Really?
Yeah.
It's kind of fucked up,
man.
They're arrogant.
Well,
they'll eat lower leaves even though
they can reach the higher ones.
They eat lower leaves and it's
speculated,
they do it because of competition for
food that they want to like literally
box out these giraffes and let them
starve to death.
She's,
well,
that's the thing that everything's been,
a friend of mine went,
everything's mean.
A friend of mine went and,
uh,
they have a similar problem that I have,
which I have a cat that's just a killing
machine.
Just kills.
Not every day just birds.
You let it out.
Birds,
lizards,
you can't keep it in.
It's a while now.
It just wants nonstop.
It's like,
I'm going outside,
so,
you know,
so we're kind of freaked out and were
like trying to stop it and putting bells
on it.
And this,
my friend had the same thing with it's
cat.
And uh,
went to Africa,
came back and said everything needs
everything.
I don't care.
It's just like it put everything in
perspective.
It's just like this is how the world
works.
Well,
this is how certainly how nature got to
2016 to 2016 by everybody just waiting
in line for food.
Being polite.
Yeah.
There's a number that they put at house
cats.
How many animals they kill every year.
And just in North America it's billions.
Billions,
billions in birds and in mammals.
Yeah.
Billions of birds and billions of
mammals.
There are just ruthless little fucker ar
and people are complaining now because
they've heard the stats and they're
like,
you shouldn't let your cats out.
And you guys,
it's just nature's cleanups the way it
goes.
That's how nature works.
Loved.
He'd,
they didn't do that though.
If they didn't have those instincts,
honestly like coyotes have coyotes were
now out there doing that.
If all these animals were now not there
doing that,
we would be overrun with rodents.
First of all,
it'd be mice everywhere cause it'd be
nothing to eat them if it weren't for
birds and hawks.
And it'd be like living in the bronx.
We have this issue at our house where
we,
um,
we just recently installed this fence
and our backyard that's glass.
And we used to have a metal fence there,
but now it's a glass fence and the hawks
haven't figured it out yet.
So every now and then you hear it and
we'll go out and sign in for what do you
have?
They're swooping down to kill Shit.
What do you got?
Chickens.
But they're not killing the chickens,
but one did disappear that we can't
totally put a finger on what happened to
it.
Oh yeah.
It could have been a coyote though.
Yeah,
that'd be bird and bird.
We've seen the bird and bird.
Super Common.
Yeah.
It's like black on black crime and no
one wants to talk about it.
It happens.
But a friend of mine was sitting in his
backyard and he watched a,
a a hawk come down scuba dove.
He said a dove was just sitting there
just chill and all of a sudden really
said it happened like 20 feet from his
face.
He was like,
what the fuck man,
this wrapped or just came down from the
sky and they take pets,
but so he's hawks,
they swooped down,
you know when they're looking for things
and then they're looking to make their
approach and they just get k the fuck
owed.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Sometimes they die.
Like we've had,
one of them died on us,
but one of them we had to take two,
one of those um,
wildlife like rescue places and they
fixed it up and took care of it.
And then another one recently got
knocked the fuck out.
Sat there was a pretty big hawk to yeah.
And my wife took video of it like,
hey buddy,
how you doing?
You Alright?
Back up girls.
And uh,
after she took video of it,
the thing eventually got ghost and Woca
fuck up and flew away,
but to coyotes come after the chickens.
Yeah.
We lost one pretty recently.
I watched it happen.
I watched the coyote hop over the fence.
Oh really?
It was weird.
Hopped over the fence,
hopped over the fence.
Fence.
I'm six feet.
What?
Yeah.
Hopped over it like it was nothing.
I mean,
just went right over the top there.
They're super,
super agile man.
Like in a weird way.
Like you're like,
wait a minute.
I didn't know you could do that.
If it went over that fence,
like it was nothing.
I'm trying to find the video.
Here it is.
This is the one or my wife was talking
to it.
Look at that thing.
That's just a hawk.
See it in front of the glass.
He's just chilling.
It's a big ass fucking hawk.
Yeah,
it's big.
he survived.
It looks like you live in the Amazon.
It looks like it.
He survived,
but he got fucking crack.
Really?
Just apply full speed right into this.
Doug.
Maybe you got to put some stickers on it
or something like if your grandma,
so she has to go through the slide.
Think last tour.
Put in Marge Simpson picture on it.
Found this video.
I was looking for a hawks swooping.
If people let a little bunny go.
Oh No,
I've seen that.
Five seconds later.
Oh,
little girl.
Little cute girl with a little bunny
rabbit.
Oh No.
Ah God,
instantly that thing just flew in.
She's asking where it's mommy is and
then a raptor.
I mean that's in some ways it's cool.
Some ways I think that's beautiful,
but in other ways like yeah,
the baby's cute,
but what is it about us where when we
look at like very small versions of
animals,
like I had a picture of the other day
that I put up on my instagram of this
giant grizzly bear with her three cubs
and I was like,
God,
look how adorable those little cubs,
others,
beautiful.
But what is going on with us where we
see these little things?
What,
what is cute?
Like in quotes,
like look at that picture.
It's a genetic thing.
It's,
it keeps us from wanting to kill them.
It's our genes and also to protect our
own.
Yeah.
So just let them thrive.
I mean you see a baby,
you want to protect it,
but like when you lose like that's why
like whenever the,
when that Connecticut school shooting
was like these tiny kids like
kindergarten,
right.
That was such a mind blowing thing
because those are the faces we want to
protect.
You know?
It's just the instinct.
Yeah,
and there's your instinct.
There's so many crazy fuckers that don't
believe that that really happened play.
Have you seen any of that?
The like people that like thing to deny
or is that these,
all these school shootings are like
false flags.
Like do you really think that you can
get all those families to lie about
losing their kids?
Exactly.
These families are all operatives.
Yeah.
They're all so CIA,
please.
People are so shitty.
People always talk always.
There's no way you can organize them.
Maybe that's me,
but to keep a secret,
but it's just amazing that people
actually would believe that that would
be something they would entertain there.
Mutans that's against nature to see this
thing and not like,
how do we make sure this doesn't happen
again?
When your head goes to,
it's a lie.
We're going to go to fleet.
This.
There's a weird thing with people.
They want to believe that a lot of
things are lies.
Like a lot of things.
Yeah.
Because the eye,
the admitting that it happens is
admitting it's chaos.
But this weird shit going on today,
like because of the Internet,
people have these forums and these
youtube pages where they make up this
nonsense.
I saw a guy the other day was who was a,
he's a flat earth guy and uh,
he had a video about how are a hoax?
2016.
Yeah.
Video about dinosaurs being a hug.
So I'm like,
wait a minute,
wait in,
wait and wait and wait and went away.
So all these paleontologists for like
what 150 years have all been foolish.
Yeah.
All in on it.
All in all,
my name's Darren,
generation to generation
also doesn't believe that satellites are
real,
right?
Satellites are not real.
They're really what's going on.
We have planes and the planes are flying
very high and they stay in orbit and
those are,
they're transmitting the signal
lord and the world's flat.
This is a real problem though.
And no,
I mean,
because that's the extreme part of it.
Like those people really believe that.
And well,
majority of people do,
but just basic thing,
there is no truth.
The Internet is,
is devouring truth sort of that there
that you can literally have real
intelligent people just talking about
unemployment rates.
Just talking about the government,
just talking about how the economy's
doing,
right,
and you can have people saying be there,
it's been lowered to below 5% of
unemployment and other people are
saying,
no,
that is completely wrong and flight.
These numbers are complete and these are
two groups of intelligent people with
degrees and putting out these facts.
It's the same thing as the official hill
thing.
It's like I can look up,
you can any fact you want to bring up,
you go on the Internet and you'll find
the opposite and not from like what
looks like crazy people.
The truth is,
I mean what is the truth?
I think right now what's happening is
virtually anybody can start a website or
a twitter page or whatever and say
anything they want and they don't have
to be correct.
Right?
But if they convince enough people,
they'll get a following and then through
that following they can get a bunch of
people that get confirmation bias and
only look into the information that
supports all this craziness.
No satellites and the earth is flat,
all that nonsense.
But I think this is almost like a
temporary blip in our road to absorbing
information.
I think right now information is coming
from a bunch of different sources.
Lots of them legit,
most of them are legit,
but then some of them that are just
really wacky like this where it gets the
sidetrack thing where people just start
thinking about chem trails are thinking
about ufo abductions and getting
absorbed in it.
But I think one of the next stages of
disbursement of information is going to
be direct brain to brain and I think
we're going to share information in some
way that is as alien to us as the
Internet would have been to people that
live to 150 years ago.
Like if you tried to explain google to
someone who lived to 150 years ago,
they'd be like,
you're out of your fucking mind.
That is never going to happen forever.
But to us it's like,
well,
Google at Jamie,
you know,
it's like it becomes normal,
right?
Well,
I think the next stage of that is you're
going to be able to access information
that directly comes from someone's mind
and meaning that you're going to be able
to share thoughts.
I think thoughts are going to be,
they're going to figure out a way to
take whatever frequency and whatever
signal that a thought is and you're
going to be able to condense it and
project it and send it to people and
you're going to be able to access other
people's thoughts and you're going to be
able to know what's truthful and what's
not.
It's not going to be a matter of,
boy,
I hope this guy's telling the truth.
You're going to,
you're going to be able to know like
pretty pretty much instantaneously.
I think that's whether it's a hundred
years from now or 200 years from now,
but all in all,
if you look at like the Roman empire or
you know,
look at like long periods of time where
one group dominated one aspect of
civilization,
a hundred years ain't shit,
but to us a hundred years ago,
1916 it's like,
might as well be Mars.
They might as well be from another
world,
you know?
But that go back to your marriage thing
of what your wife is thinking when she's
having sex with you.
You're going to no,
no,
no.
You got to see the crazy people can send
their thoughts just as easily is a no
because you don't necessarily have to
share in those thoughts,
but I just think that you'll,
you'll be able to look,
these are obviously science fiction
notions right now,
but I think that when you send a text
message to someone or put out a tweet or
a facebook message,
you're essentially condensing a thought
into some sort of a digital
representation of that thought.
And then you know,
you use the right language,
then you send it out there.
I think that what's going to happen is
it's going to be direct thought to
thought we're going to be able to
interpret thoughts and then we're gonna
just,
we're going to be able to know whether
or not someone is actually being honest
or they're,
they're bullshitting,
right?
I think,
I mean,
I think in our careers,
well that's what they say.
This is an extension of your brain.
This is my brain to this brain,
to your brain.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
So it makes sense that you're going to
bridge that gap.
That is a bridge,
right?
It's a bridge to minds and information
and ideas.
It really is,
and a lot of ways,
and I think this is just one step.
As technology exponentially grows,
we're not just gonna accept typing
things into a glass screen that will
eventually be send and then put it up
there.
It's going to be more complex.
It's going to get better.
They're going to figure out new ways to
integrate that technology into human
bodies.
That's going to be really weird,
like neural implants.
And things along those lines going to be
really wild because when they figured
out like,
see,
you wear glasses,
right?
One day they're going to say,
listen Tom,
you don't have to wear glasses.
All we have to do is install one of
these new internet neural apps.
And once we do do that,
you'll be able to see crystal clear.
There's a way that this neural APP
reworks the synapses,
right?
It changes the way your eyeballs
interpret the cones and rods interpret
the world around you and you gonna be
able to change it.
Yeah,
but I think they look good in glasses.
Look awesome.
You look smarter.
It's true.
Why don't you look smarter when you have
glasses?
Um,
I don't know.
Everybody does like chicks.
Chicks
look way smarter.
Yeah.
I don't know why that is.
Dante though.
It depends on the glasses.
Dudes look,
look you,
you know,
when you can't see good crosses,
smarter throws a glass.
I don't assume that they have something
wrong with her eyes,
I assume.
Oh,
she's smart.
She's clever.
But then Sarah Pailin fucked all that
up.
Yeah.
She says,
oh,
check glasses.
Yeah.
And she's more on,
yeah,
she just dumps that bear.
No,
but don't do the,
she's a trump supporter.
She's a real trump supporter.
I fucking trump supporter you liberal
piece of shit.
Do you think he's going to win?
I,
you know what,
I talked to a lot of people who think
it's an impossibility,
but the further we go down the road,
I think he's coming.
And I think that it's a real
possibility.
It's a real possibility.
But you know,
and I think if I was a conspiracy
theorist,
but I'm not,
I would say that what Donald Trump is
doing is making us happy about Hillary
Clinton being president because it's the
only way we're going to be happy about
Hillary Clinton being president.
Right?
Like Hillary Clinton represents the
establishment in about as clear a form
as we've ever seen before.
Right.
No question.
No.
And you know,
she's,
she's intelligent and when she was
secretary of state,
both sides liked her.
They was like,
she was really positive reviews from
everybody.
But you're right,
it's exactly the same old,
same old you ever talk about,
or you ever read the Secret Service?
Talk about guarding her.
They think she's a sociopath.
I said,
Shit.
Yeah.
They said,
first of all,
she doesn't thank anyone and she doesn't
talk to them that guard her 24,
seven and she doesn't talk to them.
They say there's a guy who,
uh,
was one of her secrets.
I mean,
he bought be a fucking idiot.
Who knows?
He might be in one guy's report.
Yeah,
right.
I think there's more than one,
but the reports were that she's just
some creepy about her.
Right.
Well,
there's some creepy about everybody.
That's another thing.
Problem with the idea that you're gonna
find one perfect person is so off the
charts.
I mean,
everybody's flawed.
Everybody's,
you know,
and especially if you play that game for
that long,
you're going to be dirty.
You're going to be duplicitous.
But that's part of what you've got to
be.
Yeah.
That game.
That's a dark game.
It's a dark game.
Did you ever see the video of her
talking about Kadafi she's laughing.
We came,
we conquered.
He died or came,
we saw he died.
Really?
Yeah.
And she's laughing.
She's doing an interview in off camera
before they interview or they're rolling
the camera while they're talking to her
and she's laughing about Kadafi dying
and you're like,
Whoa,
wait,
what?
Hold on.
Who is the person that we see that's all
measured and calm?
Like that's not you for real cause that
a act.
Right.
Cause she was like throwing her head
back laughing.
Oh boy.
And this is really weird way.
Like watch this,
watch this.
Hold on.
Go all the way from the beginning.
So
I mean that is the land of unconfirmed.
Yes,
we came,
we saw he died.
Did it have anything to do with your
visit?
No.
I'm sure it yet.
Whoa,
that's a little weird.
Well it's not jazz or weird.
It's strange what the Hillary Clinton
lying for 13 minutes straight.
We're sad about play that real quick.
But I think what you said so far,
it's super important that no one's
perfect.
Yeah.
And,
and not only that,
this business.
Yeah.
Mama's the immigration policies.
Now you say they're too harsh.
You supported his trade deal dozens of
times.
You even called it the gold standard.
Now suddenly last week,
you're against it.
Will you say anything to get elected?
Well,
actually I have been very consistent
over the course of my entire life.
I have always fought for the same values
and principles.
Looking at him.
Do you think New York state should
recognize gay?
Oh No.
Okay.
I believe that marriage is not just a
bond,
but a sacred bond between a man and a
woman.
2004.
I have uh,
not to support it.
Same sex marriage and civil partnerships
and a contractual relationships.
I support marriage for lesbian and gay
couples,
2013 Ford it personally and as a matter
of policy and law.
So you're saying your opinion on gay
marriage changed or you changed your
mind because you know,
I really,
I have to say I think you are,
um,
it was very persistent,
but you are playing with my words and
playing with what is such and I'm just
trying to clarify so I can understand.
No,
I don't think you are trying to clarify.
I think you're trying to say that,
you know,
I used to be a opposed and now I'm in
favor and I did it for political reasons
and that's just flat wrong.
So let me just state what I feel like
you are implying and repudiate it.
I have a strong record.
I have a great commitment to this issue
and I am proud of what I've done and the
progress we're making.
No,
I'm just saying I'm sorry.
I just want to clarify what I was
saying.
No,
I was saying that you maybe really
believe this all along,
but you know,
believed in gay marriage all along,
but fault for political reasons.
America wasn't ready yet and you
couldn't say it.
That's what I was saying.
No that,
no,
that is not true.
Okay.
It really is great.
How long you've supported great gay
marriage.
Yes.
I,
I could have supported it sooner.
Well you did it pretty soon.
It could have been sooner.
Fair point.
Okay.
I think we've seen enough,
but you know,
so that's just a liar.
No,
really,
that's a liar for sure.
You're alive.
But who is mine?
Terry Gross.
She was lying like in that interview was
she was saying that she always,
always supported that.
And I think old people forget that
there's the internet.
They forget.
They forget that when they said
something in 2003 there's a videotape of
it.
You'd much rather hear,
just say,
yeah,
it was,
I was always,
I was against it because I didn't think
America was ready for it.
And
or that she changed her own mind.
Right.
Changed my mind.
Just say you changed your mind.
I hate the term flip flopper right.
Because you can't evolve.
Everybody's a flip flopper.
Right.
If you're not,
then you're the same person you were
when you were five.
Right?
That's right.
Let me tell you where I stand on the
Santa thing.
No,
you're right.
Right.
I mean,
so it's the end of the day like,
fuck,
but look at what you were now.
So now look what we're faced with.
You're faced with,
that's the big thing on her is that
she's a liar and the,
and trump,
who is the biggest liar.
Right.
But you know what I mean?
But he,
but he at least says he,
he admits he's a liar.
What does he lied about?
Like what's been proven that he's lied
about?
I'm sure there's been something,
but what has been,
he goes back and forth on everything and
he goes,
he'll about Mexicans.
He's pretty strong on that.
Is Pretty strong in that,
but then says that,
uh,
maybe that was just an idea.
Maybe that was just an idea.
So when he says recently,
yeah,
maybe it was just an idea to put up the
wall.
That was the thing that he sent in a,
well now he's in the home.
These tracks,
right?
Or at least he's rounding third.
Yeah,
he's rounding third.
Right.
And more approved.
Donald Trump is a serial liar.
It's how you what though?
He's got a hot wife,
so I don't know what to say because I am
a piece of shit.
Like all man,
I'm a piece of shit.
Who's that broad you're with?
They keep one because his wife is hot.
I wouldn't mind that dame in the White
House.
Okay.
Then right now,
hey,
Laurie Clinton's built like a box.
There are of course look lying to me.
Lying politician in linings.
What kind of a baby are you that you
think that these people don't lie?
Tell me one president other than Jimmy
Carter,
perhaps that isn't a liar.
I don't think Obama is a lie.
I don't think Obama is a liar.
I do not think he's a liar.
I think that he has changed his position
on some things and I think that he said
some things before he got into office
that he wasn't really supporting or he
didn't really support once he got in
there.
But I think he is a remarkable person in
that.
As far as guys that have ever run for
president or been present,
I like listening to him talk and I like
his personality mall more than I think
anybody that's ever run for president.
I've been president.
Yeah.
And people get mad at me for saying
that.
Boom was,
what?
About what he's talking about?
Free speech.
Ooh Mama,
he did about whistleblowers.
Ooh,
boom.
I get it.
Yes.
Yes,
you're right.
Not Perfect.
Not,
not,
not even what I'm looking for.
He's not what I'm looking for.
But right out of all the other people
that have done it,
I'm like,
man,
fuck.
Remarkably thoughtful and measured,
thoughtful.
His speech,
he just gave it a Howard University.
Amazing.
It wasn't,
I didn't really listen to it.
Nobody,
nobody speaks with such clarity.
I don't understand the rage.
I really don't understand the anger and
the rage.
First of all,
we don't rely on blunt man run this fair
nation,
especially when it's a Muslim was born
in Kenya.
Can you understand that?
You're about to go against those people
are just going to go to Africa.
Once you go look where he's born.
You'll know once you get there,
because the spot,
here's a spot.
We're going to miss him.
I'll tell you what,
when he drifts off shore,
left with one of these guys,
it's going to be like,
wow.
Remember when someone was at the helm
who was just at least calm and my
perspective,
that's the thing about trump that makes
me the most nervous is just knee jerk
reactions.
Just knee jerk reactions,
which can have real consequences that we
saw not too long ago with.
Yeah,
for sure.
The presidents.
Um,
trump was a birther,
remember he was the birther.
Yeah.
Another lie.
Another calculated lie.
You don't tell me he believed that.
You don't think he believed it.
Now why was he saying it?
Because he was,
he was taking him down.
He was using it.
He caught it.
Caught fire.
But why was he like,
what was the whole point behind that for
where he is now?
You think?
Like he was thinking even back then when
he was being,
being a birther,
he was thinking that he was going to be
president.
Yeah.
He ran before this.
He did never caught,
yeah,
I don't remember that.
Did he?
Yeah,
he declared that he was going to,
that he was going to go and it never
really caught,
he would always come out at least a
flirt with the idea.
And that's what,
uh,
what kind of puzzled me with this one.
It was like,
oh,
he's just doing it again.
He's getting some Pr.
Here's the presidential campaign.
He's attaching himself to it and then
this time it went further.
God,
Hey,
try pretty hard in 2000,
I think.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's so weird.
I forgot about that.
I blocked it out.
Implicit bias.
Say whatever you can.
The thing about him that really scares
me is that he's the kind of guy that
takes the bait.
He is very sensitive and takes the bait.
And whenever you're dealing with
terrorism,
I think this is the thing that bushes I,
that,
uh,
Obama is doing more correctly is he's
not anything that happens.
He doesn't just freak out and say we've
got to act right because that's what
they want.
These are small entities and they do
things to draw this big power in and
that's how they diminish your power.
And Obama's be cool.
This is,
there's another,
you know,
he caught shit for saying,
there's a lot of ways that we can die.
Terrorism is only one of them and it's a
small one of them.
Small way,
don't take the bait,
diminish their power by not reacting.
Trump is a guy in every aspect of life
that he's reacts,
he's sensitive and freaks out and
reacts.
And I don't want that kind of,
uh,
unsettled energy,
that unsettled person to be in charge.
And that's going to,
that's going to create a frenetic way
of,
of being for the country.
That's what bothers me the most about
them.
That's a really good point.
And I think also that the president,
he represents a standard of behavior.
Yes.
When did we lose that?
Yeah.
Say what you will about Reagan.
Bush.
Lbj.
They carried themselves like adults.
Yeah.
They carried themselves.
Where you they demanded your respect.
Yeah.
Obama talks shit.
I mean I'm trump rather talk shit about
people that don't support him.
Like for no reason.
Like one of the things that he did when
Ronda Rousey got knocked out,
he uh,
said,
uh,
I'm happy she lost.
Not a good person.
Like he tweeted that,
that's like a teenage girl.
Yeah.
You want a teenage girl to be in control
of the country girl who's like 70.
Yeah.
Old Z.
How old is trump?
I'm going to put him at 65 I'm going to
put them at 64
sorry.
He's up.
Erased it from the Internet is angels.
Well that's the other thing.
The way he talks to 46 is when he was
born.
So 70 this year.
[inaudible] 70 this year.
So he,
the way he attacks,
the way he did with with her,
he goes after reporters.
Anyone that has any different view that
worm.
Yeah.
Not a good person.
This is a sad,
that's how you're going rating sad.
Yeah.
So you don't think a guy like that is
going to try and do something about the
press when he's in?
Oh yeah.
That's going to be spooky.
Shit.
It's gonna be spooky because it's,
it's weird that he has the time to do
these things while he's still a
multibillionaire running all these
companies.
Reality TV star running for president,
2000 campaign chance I'll run
millionaire considering reform party
nomination.
That was the millionaire days.
He wasn't even a billionaire back then.
Yeah.
He was just a millionaire where it was
worth 100 million.
I used to put out $100 million.
Who's going to put together a hundred
million dollar campaign just flirting
with it,
putting it out there.
He's been thinking about it forever.
All right.
Right here.
And it always seemed to me like this is
a smart pr move.
Him and Jesse Ventura.
Yeah.
I have a class act that year in January
1st about,
uh,
how to run the country.
It's called [inaudible].
It's a good title.
Uh,
Jesse Ventura was talking to him about
tower seven even before nine 11.
Yeah.
No,
I love the American wholesome Newton
side job towers,
the America.
We change.
Trump releasing a book.
The America we deserve.
We're well,
he's right.
This is the America we deserve.
No Shit.
I just hope that what's going to happen
is if he does get into office,
we'll realize that we really do need to
be smart about how we govern ourselves.
We really do need to consider it.
We're really new dean to make some real
steps to try to reform politics in this
country.
And hopefully like someone who is really
a qualified leader or someone who's
really smart and measured is looking at
this and it's going,
okay,
I've got to step in.
You know what I at this,
he's making me really Miss Romney.
Mm.
Really?
Wow.
Yeah.
He's making me Miss Romney.
At least he was us,
uh,
measured thoughtful person.
That's all.
I don't care when you hit what you think
about Obama care,
what your religion is or I don't worry
about someone who thinks they're going
to get on their own planet when they
die.
Wow.
That maybe that part is it.
They get a planet again Joe.
No one's perfect.
But you know what I mean.
Just someone who shows up and is
respectful to other people of course and
carries himself.
You're the day.
Yeah you're the guy,
you're the guy.
But what don would trump is doing is
like a exciting douche bags,
cause a lot of Douche bags out there and
they didn't have anybody that
represented them in government.
And then all of a sudden he's got them
fired up there.
His,
he's their guy,
which was fine until now when other
people who are not purportedly
douchebags who are intelligent people in
the government and in the press and
business leaders who are coming over and
saying,
okay now he's my guy.
Really?
So that's when it becomes dangerous.
That's when they lose sight of it and
start rationalizing it and say,
well,
he's not hilary,
so I'm going to go with this guy.
Did you ever see the video address of
Ted Cruz who is even more dangerous by
the way?
Ted Cruz,
the most dangerous.
He scares the fuck out of me cause he's
so dumb.
He saw what he represents is just
fucking flatline thinking and he is.
I'm standing at this rally and there's a
trump supporter in front of them with
sunglasses on,
like feet away from him.
Tell him quit drop out.
I saw that.
Yeah.
And it's just like that.
Is that that kind of a support or like
that's a new kind of supporter.
The bully,
the really aggressive man who shows up
with a sign stands in front of you with
sunglasses on.
Yeah.
Let's go tells you yet it's time to drop
out Tom Dropout.
Yeah.
And he goes,
what do you like about trump,
sir?
Everything.
Like he probably doesn't even know
anything.
Nothing that trump is supporting.
Nothing.
It's weird.
It's just bravado.
Well,
it's just weird.
I mean,
we have this culture that we're,
we're,
we're consuming nonsense all the time.
We're consuming nonsense in the form of
transformers and sitcoms and TV shows
and just,
we're,
we're constantly eating nonsense with
very little substance.
And then this guy comes along who
represents for the first time,
like a guy who's like,
why did I make America great again?
And you know,
throw your fists up in the air and that
kind of rhetoric and the,
these,
these guys just hop onto it and he's a
familiar face from the nonsense.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Reality TV's guy that you've listened to
before.
So strange.
Yeah.
Scary.
It's a really,
it's a,
it's a real telling thing of where we
are with the media,
but how much power does the president
actually have?
A little will highlight it once he gets
into office,
like the,
what would congress and
yeah,
because look,
Iraq,
which is arguably one of the greatest
mistakes in centuries of just all the
evidence of what's happening over there
to those poor people.
Uh,
that happens because that guy is in
charge.
So yeah,
there are real global consequences to
who's ever in that office.
And he's bringing in like real political
masterminds to try to organize his
campaign from here on out.
Yeah.
So I feel like he got to the dance.
He's essentially,
they haven't made him the Republican
nominee,
but there's no one else.
Nope.
No one's stepping up.
How would that happen?
Like is there a,
is there a possibility that he could not
be the nominee?
Is there any way?
Not any longer.
No.
Wow.
The only car,
the only curve ball could be that.
Um,
and this is,
well,
there's a couple of curve balls.
There's many curve balls.
But,
uh,
a third party candidate could arise and
say that they're going to go for,
it was another scary curve ball is that
it stays the way that it is.
And Hillary gets past Bernie and it's,
it's Hillary and trump and they start
going to battle.
And then this,
uh,
the Bengazi reports and everything that
she's being investigated for their
sailing in the New York Times today that
they're holding,
they're slowing down that process so
that she shit comes out about her like
on the eve of the election.
Really?
Yeah.
You like that stuff?
The Republican House who's
investigating?
So they're virtually guaranteeing that
she,
they,
it's almost like they have a bomb,
right?
They're going to drop it at the proper
time.
It's their one shot,
not just Ben Gazi.
It's also the email server,
the email and cloud sending classified
emails.
I had Mike Baker on,
he's a former CIA operative and he's
pretty blake blunt about it.
He said,
look,
if I did what she did,
I'd be in jail.
Right.
And he's like,
we have top secret,
secret clearances,
all those different levels for a reason.
Yeah.
You're responsible.
Take information from those emails that
are top secret and then just cut and
paste and put them in emails that are
going through a regular server.
You can't do it.
Right.
And the fact that this guy in Romania
who some hacker character,
he's like reading all her emails like
wow.
Crazy.
Very scary.
So the,
so back to your original question.
Yeah,
he could be your president.
I think he might be.
What's going on.
Did you see this got announced
yesterday?
What does it take the power back power
back to all over La.
Yesterday there was a,
these,
I don't know,
posters were posted all around with this
Hashtag and profits of rage.com
was the website to go to and there's
just a countdown on this website that
goes to June 1st which I'm not 100% sure
of is that if that's the date of the RNC
in Cleveland I think.
I think it's pretty close to it.
Either way.
What has been announced I think has been
coming out of the last 24 hours is that
members of rage,
the machine,
public
enemy and Cypress Hill are getting back
together and they're going to start
doing some political concerts.
It seems like and concert with the RNC
against the RNC.
I mean,
that's what Reggie gets machine was
doing a long time ago.
Here's the thing,
if it's not the Republicans,
then it's the Democrats.
And is Hillary Clinton much better?
Yes.
Is she much better than him?
Just because of stability.
I mean,
she's not perfect.
I'm not a democrat or a Republican,
but there,
that man is an irrational television
star.
He's a bad guy.
You don't want that.
She's not perfect.
But there's stability and is,
I just want calm uptime.
Gimme calm.
Give me people who have been there.
He's bringing in these like real estate
thugs from Atlantic city to be his
advisor.
He's a nut bag who goes on twitter like
a 12 year old girl and starts getting in
fights with people.
Not the president of the United States.
Entertaining.
Sure.
But come on.
Well now that he's sort of achieved the
helm of the Republican Party,
um,
did you see that Megan Kelly thing now,
Megan Kelly,
they did an interview recently of a kiss
and makeup.
She kissed his ass.
Really?
Yeah.
That's by all means by all accounts.
She kissed his ass and they made it
about the two of them.
Right.
Made it about there.
The little relationship together,
their,
their interactions together.
But he's been shitting on our culinary a
hack forever.
Look at this.
It's what he does believe for who?
Megan Kelly interview of Donald Trump
made it clear.
Once again,
the definition of bullying has extended,
expanded almost to the point of
meaninglessness.
Yeah.
It kind of has like whenever someone
like gets upset at someone,
they're a bully.
Now it's a bully,
right?
Yeah.
If you have power,
you're a bully.
He's the most scary to me.
When he gets calm.
Like that just starts talking like
pretending to be a grownup.
Hold on.
The liquid is saying here,
all my exclusive.
Look at this.
They didn't use the occasion.
Talk about politics or policy.
Instead,
they talked almost exclusively in the
[inaudible] version of the conversation
about bullying.
What most kids between the age of six
and 16 had been bullied at some point in
their life,
uh,
lives.
Kelly's told trump she paused.
Were you ever bullied?
No,
I wasn't trump reply.
But I have seen bullying and bullying.
Doesn't have to be as a child,
just have to be as a child.
I mean,
I know people were bullied when they're
55 it can have when you're 45 Kelly
replied,
Oh hey,
what about 44
what about talking about opioids?
Killing Americans.
How about talking about about
cigarettes.
How about talking about how you're going
to take millions,
11 million people and try and push them
down to Mexico on Day One?
Well,
she was insinuating,
I guess that she had 45 was being
bullied by trump because of tweets.
But when someone,
he said he continued simply it happens,
we've got to get over it,
fight back,
do whatever you have to do.
But it when someone criticizes you and
then you criticize them and they are a
national newscaster and near a national
figure too.
What's bullying?
Like?
Where is it?
Where's that bullying?
Whereas that someone who is insulting,
it's insulting someone.
Bullying is shitting on someone
bullying.
Like when does it like that word
bullying to me is like a bigger person
picking on a smaller person with a small
person can't do anything.
Right.
Well,
she clearly has a voice of her own
right,
and she clearly is a person of power and
influence and she's on television.
Yeah,
I'm confused.
Even who's bullying who in that
scenario,
because she is powerful because she has
a,
she has the media.
He's powerful because he had the mic.
Yeah,
well she's way more classy about it for
sure.
And her criticisms are fairly valid and
it's all things that she believes need
to be addressed.
So I don't think she's bullying him,
but as he bullying her by insulting her.
How's that?
Is that bullying or is it just insult.
Okay.
Leah,
this saying,
let me ask you about that.
Because most American parents are trying
to raise their kids to not believe,
to name,
call,
not tease,
not taunt.
How can they effectively bring that
message to the front runner?
Oh,
when the front runner for the Republican
nomination does all of those things,
he says,
well,
I do it really,
you know,
I've been saying during this whole
campaign that I'm a counterpuncher.
You understand that I'm responding now.
I then respond times may be 10 what?
Okay.
I don't know.
I respond pretty strongly,
but in just about all cases,
I've been responding to what they did to
me.
So it's not a one way street.
Okay.
Uh Huh.
I don't know if this is brilliance.
You're talking about all of this instead
of yeah.
Right.
So crazy that,
yeah.
So she's essentially painting herself as
a victim and wanting to talk to this guy
who bullied her and wanting him to
address the idea and concept of
bullying.
Yeah.
And uh,
he's like,
Hey,
I'm a counter puncher.
Fuck with me.
I fuck you back.
Well,
his,
his thing is you do,
you do come out and bully.
He beats the shit out of boom.
And then it was like,
Hey,
Ted Cruz is a nice guy.
Oh good.
He's been acting nice to me for a
second.
He's going to be his running mate.
I don't know how about that.
Fat Guy from New Jersey,
he might go with,
uh,
um,
the fat guy from New Jersey.
They,
they've been together a lot.
He told the fat guy from New Jersey that
he's going to be the guy in charge of
his transition team to the White House.
Did you see the fat guy in New Jersey,
porn,
m,
and m's into his bag of M and.
M's?
I had two bags of M and.
M's.
He had a large bag of m and m's in a
small bag of M and.
M's and he poured the large,
the small bag into the large bag that
fucking tried to,
Oh,
a bit of credit for that.
Like this,
the way it's packaged and it's just a
box of m and ms with a small one inside,
whatever that might get.
The rose is a monster.
I think m and m meeting monster,
I would think he probably goes with,
um,
was the governor of Arizona.
The woman who was yelling at Jan brewer.
No fucking way.
I don't think so.
She's way too dumb.
She's
scary.
Scary,
Dom.
Have you ever seen her interrogated or,
or an interview if someone questions are
and gives her a hard time.
I just see her yelling.
She just represents scared old people
live in Arizona.
You know,
that's how they scooped her up.
Scare old people is you know,
good group to go for right now.
Tom Papa,
you worried about the world.
You're a bright guy,
a thoughtful guy.
I'm pretty optimistic about the world
actually.
What's going to happen,
uh,
to the world and with this whole
election thing with his election to
learn from this.
I don't know if we're going to learn
from this.
I don't think we learned from uh,
the Bush era.
I don't think we've learned that much.
I think we're going through a little bit
of a,
a dark time where you know,
people that make a lot of noise,
you have someone thoughtful like Obama
who wants to just have people discussing
if people embraced and we're able to
debate with him rather than just block
him.
He wouldn't have won all of his things,
but the other side would have been more
thoughtful as well and we would have,
wouldn't be in the place we are now.
I think we're in this new media,
this new way of digesting information
that's very confusing to people.
And some bad people are taking advantage
of it,
but I think ultimately we're going to
sift through and uh,
and good people and good ideas will come
to the,
to the forefront.
I don't know how,
but I'm pretty optimistic that that's
the way it goes.
Heavy evil ways tend to die off and go
away.
So I'm,
I'm pretty optimistic.
A powerful message from Tom.
Bob,
I hope you write more piano.
I think people are nicer now than
they've ever been before.
I really do.
And I think one of the things about it
is billy discussion,
this discussion is a,
is an important discussion.
Bullying is a real problem and it
wouldn't,
that discussion wouldn't be taken place
10 years ago,
20 years ago.
Nobody give a fuck about bullying.
Like suck it up,
bitch.
We all got bullied.
No,
you're right.
I mean pretty quickly that's happened,
right?
I just can't believe he said he never
got bullied.
How'd you never got bullied?
If you're the bully I guess.
But he's always been the bullies.
Whole light show.
He needs someone to bully him.
I bet if someone came out and bullied
him,
like one of them Koch brothers,
that'd be funny.
Like I used to bully him fucking pussy.
You Suck my Dick.
When he owed me a million,
we survive up balls on his face in sixth
grade.
He would cry.
It was hilarious.
We fuck his hair out and then he starts
tweeting back.
Sad exclamation point,
smelling balls,
hit balls.
Always smelled sad.
No,
but I'm pretty optimistic and you know
what,
it's,
you know,
it's interesting and I think,
I don't know,
I'm talking out of my ass,
but I,
we all are.
But I do feel like,
uh,
when you travel around and you do your
shows and stuff,
there's the thing that's lost and all of
this discussion is there's,
there's Americans,
there's just plain old Americans who
don't say,
I'm purely Republican and purely
Democrat.
I'm just screw the other side at all
costs.
There are just working people that are
just,
just Americans.
Like what happened to America being the
thing that we're all working towards and
suss these people out for what's going
to be better for our kids and for the
country.
I feel like the Internet is going to
sift through this bullshit.
I mean what we're seeing really with
trump in a way is kind of this implosion
of that party because they let the crazy
tea party right wing part of it devour
it and now they're in chaos.
Maybe that's a sign that people that are
extreme won't survive.
They'll kind of devour and devolve into
something else.
Well,
not only that,
there were people were ganging up to try
to stop trump in the party like Marco
Rubio and Ted Cruz.
They had like this pack they were going
to like try to figure out a way to stop
trump from moving forward.
Right.
And trump,
in my eyes,
at least if I'm looking at it,
I think he's looking at this as like an
accomplishment.
This is Mount Everest to climb to become
the president.
Whereas I don't think he's looking at in
terms of really serving the United
States people.
I don't think he's that guy.
No,
I don't think that's,
I mean that's not why he's so
successful.
He's so successful because he,
he represents his own shit.
He knows how to do it.
He gets it done.
He's easy,
egocentric comic who doesn't have much
of an act but becomes really successful
cause he believes in him so much.
I know who you're talking about.
I'm talking about that guys,
a couple of them.
But no,
it's,
that'd be listening right now when
there's that narcissistic thing,
right.
You do become successful because you
want it more than anyone wants you to go
away.
Yeah.
We certainly,
it can be done.
I mean,
he's showing that he can get so close.
Yeah.
But I don't still know if Hillary can
beat him.
And Bernie's,
I know that's kind of the thing.
Do you like Bernie?
I like him as a character.
I followed him on twitter just because
he was an independent when he was an
independent.
He was just like this little rebel from
Vermont.
And he just seemed like a cool,
I've always loved Vermont and it seemed
like this free thinking area.
I liked him more of just following him
that way.
His ideas of,
you know,
of socialism and uh,
and I don't say that as a,
as a real,
you know,
democratic socialist is not a scary,
like mindless thing.
But,
uh,
I don't see him being that good of a
leader.
I don't see him being,
he's,
he is pretty extreme.
He is pretty extreme and it,
I it,
I don't see him as a PR.
I loved him as like a senator from
Vermont.
I like the idea of trying someone to
extreme,
just who we can see what's wrong with
it.
Well that's the trump thing.
That is the trump thing.
I voted for parole at one point.
Oh,
did you?
Yeah,
I did too.
I just wanted this,
this guy who was making some sense,
he's not perfect,
but fuck,
let's,
let's throw the card table up in the air
and see where we're at.
There's a new game at the end of the
day.
Do you remember when Perot had that ad
on television or he took out an entire
half hour of television and bought it?
Yes.
And then explain why the irs is fucking
you.
Yeah.
Ooh,
I know.
I remember like my jaw dropping.
I don't watch that going.
Why?
I know it wasn't,
wasn't totally off base and that's why
honestly that's why I get why people
want trump without even knowing that
much opposition of the issues.
It's like,
let's,
let's rock this.
Let's,
let's,
let's blow this thing up.
Just it was not serving me.
When you want a loss in their boys hair,
nails,
ladies and gentlemen,
what does he say?
Good.
Crank it up there.
Maybe now's the time for me to waive the
voters deck and get rid of the heck,
but it'll take a lot more than that.
It would take millions of years showing
up on November the third to get rid of
this hex.
He'd been mind.
The value of the dollar is going down.
The number of people making less than
$12,000
is going up.
I don't want to bore you with this
statement that trickled down,
didn't trickle work.
We have 19th century century capitalism
and this kind of cree are successful.
International competitors are practicing
modern day capitalism.
We need to practice 21st century
capitalism.
We need an intelligent,
supportive relationship between
government and business.
We need longterm thinking.
We need to target the industries of the
future and make sure they are here and
the words made in the USA or written
across them.
We need to have the most rapidly growing
small business society in the world
because we can create more jobs more
quickly.
They're all of this can be done.
Kidnap his daughter.
They did.
They threatened to who did some fucking
bad people.
Yeah,
those ever here.
He dropped out.
Remember when he was running for
president and he dropped out and then
reentered back in late in the race and
it was too late,
but he dropped out based on credible
threats to the security of his family.
I'm like,
those are the days that they could just
scoop your kids up.
Shit.
You know back in the 80s they can get
away with something like that.
They get to actually pull it off.
Was it the eighties or was it the
nineties back then?
[inaudible] 90 I think he ran in
[inaudible] 90 but anything pre
internet.
Well,
let's see what it is.
And He,
Jamie,
1992 campaign Dol Perot says he quit in
July to thwart g gop dirty tricks
decision July in a matter of a campaign.
But bubba,
I said,
had withdrawn hearing,
President Bush's campaign was scheming
to smear his daughter with a computer
altered photograph and to disrupt her
wedding.
Mr Pro offered no evidence,
but I thought it was also worried about
kidnapping.
Can't prove any of it today.
I said on tonight's CBS news program,
60 minutes,
but it was a risk and a risk.
I did not have to take my daughter's
concerned and a risk I would not take
where my daughter's concerned.
Hmm.
Who knows,
man?
Well,
it scared him and he's a tough,
he was a tough guy.
There's no,
he's still alive with,
we need a prototype character.
So Richard Branson,
American,
no,
dammit.
But that's,
you know,
trump has a little of that,
right?
Trump is saying,
why are we sending these jobs over here
and why?
Right.
So he's that he's garnering up some of
that.
If it works,
what did he gets in and he actually does
a good job.
Yeah.
What if,
what if he gets in and just has everyone
suck his dick?
Shut up.
Fuck off.
Well,
the rest of you're fired.
Everyone's fired.
Well that's kind of,
that's why,
that's why the Republican establishment
doesn't like,
doesn't like him.
It's not that he's reckless.
It's that he's,
he's rich and he also holds views in the
past that were more left than right.
Yeah.
You know,
he's a complex dude.
His complex dude who farted me.
It smells like bear.
It's not that bad.
Um,
Tom Papa,
where you next man?
Where can people see ya?
Um,
let's see.
I am going to a levity live.
Which one is not Yak.
Oh,
that's a good one.
I act in New York.
I'm going there soon.
Thanks.
Yeah,
it's a good club.
It's a good spot.
And I'm a shooting my special in a,
the end of June.
It looks like,
what are you doing it for?
A epics,
Hulu and Amazon.
Excellent.
Yeah.
How Amazon's getting into things the
same way a Netflix says they went their
own original programming and yeah,
that's cool man.
Yeah,
this show that I'm,
I a,
I write on the show called Red Oaks,
which is Amazon show that Paul risers in
red oaks.
It's all heard of it.
So it's good to brand new.
One season's out and we're shooting the
next season.
There's so much content today.
It's amazing.
Crazy.
I know.
I'm going to shoot,
I'm going to do a,
a role in it too in a couple of weeks.
Nice.
And uh,
yeah,
it's on Amazon.
You'd like it.
It's all about a country club in the
80s.
It's just like an eighties caddyshack
kind of a show and polarizers in it and
uh,
Richard kind and you really funny the
Amazon has the new version of top gear.
Oh really?
Yeah.
You want with that I'm on with Jeremy
Clarkson and Richard May and James
Hammond,
the original crew were top gear.
Do you know the whole story behind it?
The guy punched one of the producers.
They fired him.
Jeremy Clarkson.
Yeah,
it's pretty great.
he's awesome.
But,
uh,
yeah,
him and the producer like get along
fine.
They just,
you know,
they had a blow up and in the what to do
with the English BBC,
they had a bit of a row,
bit of a row,
knocked him out,
you know,
it probably would have to be fine now
and something happened and they fired
him.
And um,
the other two guys were like,
we're with you dude.
We're not going anywhere.
And so they recast top gear right now.
Top in the UTA Ucas,
like five new hosts.
Yeah.
So it's uh,
one of them being my friend Richard
Harris who's amazing or Chris Harris.
I shouldn't,
he's really my friend.
I should actually name good name though.
I think of Richard Hammond,
Chris,
this 20 fucking English people,
but Chris Harris is my favorite,
a British Carter Mum,
one of my favorite journalists,
period.
Car Journalist.
Oh yeah.
He's awesome at it.
And he's just one of the new top gear
guys.
Chris Harris,
and um,
but Richard Hat,
Richard Hunt,
Richard Hammond and James May and Jeremy
Clarkson or the original Dream Team and
those guys together were,
there was the most popular show in the
whole world.
They were awesome.
The world,
the whole world.
And when it got canceled,
you know,
they moved over to Amazon so they had to
wait a certain amount of time.
I think it's been over a year and now
they're going to do it on Amazon.
So that's great.
It'll boost Amazon for sure.
For sure.
And uh,
maybe it'll boost Tom Paul.
Yeah.
Maybe my little special be good.
And I'm still cranking out my podcasts,
my come to Papa podcast.
It's a little endeavor and that's it.
Do you have a little studio set up at
your place?
I just have like this little,
uh,
h four recorder and he's bring it
places.
I just have it.
No,
I do it.
Well,
I do the Sirius Xm show and uh,
I do that in the studio and then it
moves on raw dog.
Okay.
I've been doing that for a long time and
then he leaves live.
Come to papa shows,
which are like a prairie home companion.
You should do it sometime.
It's really good.
It's like scripted old classic radio.
We do sketch stuff.
He just read on stage and then some
comedians do a set,
he'd do it in the audio music.
We do it at Largo and then we do it in a
village underground.
And do you have comics to actual stand
up?
Yeah,
they do their act on your podcast?
Yeah.
Why would anybody do that though?
Because then that releases their
material.
Ah.
Who hears it of fucking podcast.
Is this how many people are living?
Well,
you know,
they do older material or they just try
stuff out or it's only like a five
minute set.
Okay.
I don't know.
Darnt you beyond being so precious with
your material,
like don't you want so precious?
Yeah.
Like people hear it.
I don't care where I do my act at this
point.
It's,
you know,
yeah.
People want to hear it all the time
or sitting in front of you with a,
with a camera pointing at you while
you're on stage doesn't work out.
If you're working on some new shit,
it weirds me out,
but I don't care.
Wow.
Tom Pop.
You still relaxed?
No.
But why?
What's the regular foot massages?
What do you do that keeps you so calm?
I really,
I kind of stopped worrying about that
stuff.
That's good.
Cause I mean,
everything's everywhere.
Everything's everywhere.
I put,
so I'm going to put this special out.
The day it comes out.
Kids are going to rip it,
put it around for free.
Hopefully.
Yeah,
hopefully.
Right.
So you actually want people to steal
your stuff in some ways.
So like if you had a show at the ice
house and they're like,
they're going to record it.
I would just shift my thinking like,
all right,
so I'm not going to do that one bit.
I'll,
I'll do this other bid or whatever.
You know?
The point is that people can see it all
the time,
everywhere.
So who cares if it's on a podcast,
I guess,
I guess you can look at it that way.
I always look at it like when you see it
live,
leading up to the filming was special.
It's a work in progress.
Yeah.
And uh,
if you see it,
it's like you could read spoiler alerts
about game of thrones online if you want
to.
Sure.
But it'll kind of fuck up the story for
you.
Right.
So if you see like bits that are a work
in progress like six months ago and then
you see him again,
you get to see the work that's been done
so you could look at it that way.
Like I see the progress and it's kind of
cool as a fan of comedy,
do you watch that?
Like I like watching other people work
stuff I like,
like Tony Hinchcliffe
as this new bit.
I don't want to give away the premise,
but I've been watching this bit grow and
he comes off and he's like,
super pumped dude.
You see the new version?
I'm like,
I love it.
I love that new thing.
And you know,
we start talking about it,
but that's,
I'm a comedy Geek.
I'm,
I like the process itself where some
people just want to see the actual bit
when it's done,
but that's how I feel like the comedy
geeks will know my,
my me do my bit on the podcast and then
see it in my special ed.
But the regular fans,
they're just going to see the special.
I see what you're saying.
You know what I mean?
I Dunno.
I just feel like it's our job now and
the way that,
the way that people can digest material,
it's our job to crank stuff out and be
making stuff,
doing podcasts and doing your material
and writing books and just,
just crank and create and put it out
there.
So if you see my Ra said at Largo,
that's what you,
that's what I put out today.
And if I'm going to do my special or I'm
going to do a thing in red oaks and
that's that thing,
you know,
so it's,
it's just all output from the Papa
compound,
the Papa compound,
ladies and gentleman,
Tom Papa folks.
So great.
It was fun.
I enjoyed it.
Nice watching eat bread.
I never thought anybody ever say that by
fuckers.
Okay.
Yeah.